Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere kosmische Angelegenheiten mein name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle zu nummer zweiundachtzig unserer gesprächsserie über.
alles was die welt so bewegt.
Und heute ist mal wieder so ein besonderer tag weil ich habe mich mal ganz weit aus meinem studio weg entfernt und hab die reise angetreten nach england konkret befinde ich mich jetzt.
Milton jeans an der open versinkt y.
Und das habe ich gemacht um mal über den maß zu sprechen wir haben schon mal bei den maß gesprochen über den mars als solchen was dort alles so ist auch bei maß express die elsa mission die wir hier schon mal ein thema,
aber heute möchte ich mich konkreter auf all die dinge.
Konzentrieren die dort am boden stattfinden über die rover sprechen und was dort für wissenschaft betrieben wird und dazu begrüße ich zunächst einmal meine gesprächspartnerin mich doktor susanne schlenzer hallo schönen guten tag.
Hallo vielen dank.
Herzlich willkommen zur raum zeit ja frau schmelzer sie sind gelogen richtig.
Mineral login genauer gesagt aber ich gehe auch als biologe durch denn das kann man so ja nicht ganz genau trennen ich habe mineral energie in mainz studiert ähm mit dem schwerpunkt georg chemie und thermodynamik.
Und dann auch in mainz meine doktorarbeit gemacht da max bank institut dort über maß meteoriten und.
War das schon immer ihr ziel so wissenschaftlerin zu werden.
Eigentlich nicht nein eigentlich wollte ich journalist werden und heute vielleicht auf der anderen seite sitzen und äh jemanden interviewen aber die maß meteoriten hamstern geschafft und habe mich für die wissenschaft eingefangen.
Wie kriegt man denn da die kurve also.
Durch die begeisterung durch das was sie erforschen können und letztlich als journalist
möchte man dinge herausfinden und möchte man hintergründe erkunden
und als wissenschaftler möchte man das auch und als ich begonnen habe für meine die situation zu arbeiten und äh festgestellt habe was man
am mars alles erforschen kann die faszination der raumfahrt entdeckt habe und für mich entdeckt habe dann war es irgendwie und dann hab ich gedacht naja kannst du vielleicht noch eine poste stelle irgendwo annehmen und
dann ist es so weitergegangen.
Das heißt die entscheidung für mineral logi e stand schon nach der entscheidung auch konkret sich auf die raumfahrt und die erforschung des all zu konzentrieren oder war das dann eher nach.
Das eigentlich wollte ich ähm gleich journalist werden aber dann hat mein vater so gesagt naja wenn du nicht irgendwie nur im lokal journalismus hängen bleiben möchtest
aber sondern wenn du wirklich den großen journalismus machen willst dann.
Die ganzen lebensläufe an die leute haben alle irgendwie ein studium absolviert,
na ja gut dann gucken wir uns mal an dann mache ich erst bei geschichte aber das hat mich dann doch nicht so interessiert und dann hab ich die chemie für mich,
aber da ich zu den geburtenstarken jahrgänge gehört habt dann waren die chemie häuser voll bis zum.
Und dann bin ich in den app wissenschaften gelandet mein vater war geologie meine mutter geographic bin bin ich so mal an einem tag der offenen tür der uni mainz zu den georg wissenschaftlern gegangen und fand das einfach total fasziniert.
Eigentlich habe ich immer gesagt ich wollte will das nicht machen weil möchte ich wirklich jedes mal am wochenende nach hause kommen und gefragt werden und was habt ihr die woche gemacht von eltern dies jahr in dem zudem im moment besser wissen na ja aber dann habe ich die mineral energie gesehen und fand das einfach so faszinierend und so spannend dass ich gedacht hab
eigentlich na ja wenn sie zu viel fragen brauchst du auch nicht nach hause zu gehen
aber es war da nie so wir haben uns wunderbar unterhalten denn das was wir gelernt haben in der mineral energie das hat meine eltern ja nur endlich mit.
Und meine eltern wussten dinge die ich so nie gelernt habe weil man kann ja nicht alles machen in paar jahren studium und so bin ich zum mineral gekommen und habe
dann beschlossen ich äh promovieren auch noch hab nebenbei schon journalismus gemacht bei der rhein zeitung in mainz gearbeitet auch viel ehrenamtlich journalismus gemacht
zehn jahre für den verein lahn marmor museum äh die zeitschrift
betreut und auch meditiert habe also sehr viel als journalist gemacht während meinem studium und auch noch während meiner doktorarbeit und bin dann aber während der
arbeit irgendwie immer mehr dazu gekommen dass meine berufung dann doch irgendwas sabor ist und die zahlen und das wirklich herausfinden von dingen und das weitergeben von leuten gemacht werden kann die das,
können als ich und die da mehr talent haben als ich.
Was ist denn so faszinierend an mineral logi e.
Genau wie die physik die chemie erklärt die mineral logi e,
zusammenhänge im weiteren bereich auch mineralöle brauchen sie als bau materialien mineralöle sind die grundlage einer umwelt.
Es ist zum beispiel ein unterschied ob sie sagen wir mal auf dem.
Stehen wo sie bei salzige steine haben oder im schwarzwald wo sie granit gestein haben weil die andere chemische zusammensetzungen haben deshalb werden die böden anders deshalb sind die
pflanzen andere selbst wenn sie an einer stelle wären wo temperatur und niederschlags menge und alles das
gleiche wäre die steine bilden ihnen die chemie und die steine sind aus mineralien zusammengesetzt sie haben also dort eine.
Grundlage dessen was einen bestimmten ort ausmacht aber sie haben auch die mineral logik als material wissenschaft wenn sie eine,
armbanduhr nehmen die batterie betrieben ist dann haben die heißen alle quarz ohren weil es da ein zu elektrischen quarz kristall drin hat der dafür sorgt dass die uhr eine uhr ist weil er eben in einem bestimmten rhythmus schwingt und damit die uhr gehen lässt.
Und das alles ist die mineral logik zement ist mineral energie alles was sie in organischen materialien erstellen
ist letzten endes mineral energie.
Außerdem ist die symmetrie der mineralöle auch faszinierend und fast schon künstlerisch also es ist ein sehr weites feld das da faszination auslöst.
Und wie kriegt man den sprung von den mineralien zum weltraum.
Ich habe mich sehr stark für analytic interessiert und auch chemie georg chemie gemacht ähm und in meinem grund studium.
Und auch meine diplomarbeit war 'ne massen spektrum metallische arbeit und dann hab ich mich nach der situationen umgesehen
und dann war gerade zu dem zeitpunkt aussehen ein großes thema was auch analytisch sehr stark eingebunden war aber.
Das thema was sich dann zufällig entdeckt habe solche dinge sind ja ganz oft zufall ich hab mich nach
stellen umgesehen hauptsächlich im bereich georg chemie ich wollte in die umwelt gehe chemie aussehen war ein thema
andere schwermetalle war ein thema und dann plötzlich in all den stellenanzeigen ihr kommt eine stellenanzeige raus die sagt edel gase in mars meteoriten.
Ist eine sehr seltene technik ist etwas was ich noch nie gemacht hatte
alleine hat mich schon fasziniert aber wenn dann die stellenanzeige sagt es ist eine max bank institut.
Da wissen wir alle dass das eben ein forschungs- institut ist wo man mit sehr vielen extrem guten leuten zusammenarbeiten kann und da habe ich gedacht na ja du schreibst meine bewerbung wirst du nie kriegen,
na ja es ist anders gekommen und zum glück anders gekommen.
Und das war dann in mainz.
Das war in mainz am max bank institut in mainz zeit als denke und b mann noch direktorin waren also keine schwenke noch direktor war und dann ähm unter druck meier auch.
Das heißt wir sprechen jetzt von ende der neunziger jahre miteinander ja.
Ich ende der neunziger jahre ich hab zweitausendvier mein abschluss gemacht.
So und da ging 's ja dann auch auf maß schon heiß her.
Ja ähm ich war im grund studium noch dann hat er hat das max blank institut des instrument auf
pass finde geschickt und das hab ich nur am rande mit
bekommen ich war am max bank institut als ähm hey wie man so schön sagt ab und zu tätig steine klein machen solche sachen hilfst arbeiten eben aber das bekommt man natürlich mit
da sind dann seminare und dann sind plötzlich auch bei haufenweise journalisten da wenn irgendwas gerade aktuell ist
aber die hauptsache für mich war halt zum einen zu sehen was die kollegen machen die daten die die kollegen zurückbekommen
irgendwelche dinge zu sehen zu erforschen die so noch nie jemand gesehen hat das war eigentlich eine der grundlagen.
X ist das alpha partikel spektrum meter auf der marktpassage mission der nasa die dann sozusagen dafür verwendet wurde dort die chemischen elemente zu untersuchen nämlich alle.
Das ist eine analyse die sie da machen.
Und diese gestein analyse ist sehr vergleichbar mit dem was wir hier auf der erde machen würden und sie können damit eben das gestein als solches bestimmen und damit auch wieder die umweltbedingungen bestimmen.
Das heißt das hat man so mitbekommen weil weil es quasi in mainz gab es eine abteilung die sich mit diesem instrument instrument gebaut hat oder okay.
Rudolf frida und ralf gelernt haben das instrument gebaut in mainz und dann eben wurde es von der nasa in den oberen integriert.
Der rosa war der jona.
Zuerst desto journal das ist auf dem turnier geflogen das ist auf den mars expression rover spirit and opportunity geflogen und es ist jetzt auf m s l.
So was braucht man einfach.
Man braucht ein instrument das genaue gescheites chemie liefert und das objekt ist eines von vielen instrumenten das gedauert gestein chemie liefert.
Auf dem mars zwanzig zwanzig dem in der zukunft ist es nicht mehr drauf es ist nicht auf jede mission geflogen aber auf diesen robert mission ist es geflogen ich kann mir aber durchaus vorstellen dass es in zukunft auch mal wieder fliehen.
Okay aber damit hatten sie jetzt sozusagen erstmal am anfang nichts mit zu tun mit diesem instrument das fand nur statt und man kriegt ihr das so mit und das wahrscheinlich ein bisschen ins gespräch.
Das war das gesprächsthema das war das thema viele seminare dann kommen natürlich internationale kollegen die doch im labor arbeiten die dort im labor zu gange sind und die dann auch vorträge halten man bekommt es also dann
deutlicher mit als man es mitbekommen würde wenn man jetzt nur an der universität ist dadurch dass ich eben auch äh am max bank damals schon als assistent gearbeitet hab und
man bekommt die die faszination der erforschung hautnah mit.
Aber dann hat es nicht in mainz gehalten lange also.
Relativ lange aber dann auch wieder nicht lange ich hab nachdem ich meine die situation abgeschlossen hatte noch drei jahre in mainz weitergearbeitet an den themen die ich während meiner die situation bearbeitet hab hauptsächlich edel gase in maß meteorit
aber auch edel gas fraktionen näherung also was passiert wenn atmosphäre und steine in kontakt
kommen was bleibt am gestein haften was wird
absolviert um das dem fach ausdruck zu benutzen und was eben nicht und welche veränderungen finden da statt das war mein forschungsgruppe.
Du musst keine fragen maß meteoriten darin wir jetzt von gestein was vom maß kommt aber es auf die erde geschafft hat oder okay.
Also meteoriten generell ist ja extra restliches material das von irgendwo anders aus der erde kommt und hier auf der erde landet.
Da frage ich mich halt immer woher weiß man denn dann das vom maß kommt.
Für die maus meteorit ist die mission entscheidend denn bikini neunzehnhundert.
Ich hat ein massen spektrum meter gehabt und hat die zusammensetzung der maß atmosphäre gemessen.
Und die krypton verhältnisse die damals gemessen worden in der maß atmosphäre stimmen mit denen überein die in die in den.
Impakt gläsern also glas material in diesen meteoriten eingeschlossen sind man kann natürlich auch andere.
Dinge.
In parkhäusern dadurch dass es in die atmosphäre eintritt und durch die einsetzung bildet sich sozusagen diese gläser beim eintritt.
Die gläser bilden sich bereits auf dem mars wenn sie einen anschlag karte haben dann haben sie dann wird ja die gesamte energie des.
Deals das.
Diese planeten oder sommer planeten oberfläche auftritt trifft wird ja die gesamte genetische energie wird dann im prinzip in wärme umgewandelt das heißt sie wenn der einstiegs körper groß genug ist schmelzen sie.
Größere mengen gestein und haben dann in diesem geschmolzenem bereich was was.
Passiert ist dieses projektil trifft auf die oberfläche und dringend solange in die oberfläche ein bis die gesamte kinetische energie aufgebraucht ist und was dann passiert ist mit einer explosion zu vergleichen.
Wenn sie im plakate ähm von ihrer motto logi e vergleichen wollen ist es nicht
eine delle die wie durch einen hammer schlag passiert sondern das können sie am besten vergleichen mit den atombomben test geraten die passiert sind wenn sie also eine sehr große menge energie unter
unter der oberfläche freisetzt.
Das passiert dann und dadurch wird sehr viel material heraus geschleudert und damit können material so stark beschleunigt werden dass es einen planeten verlassen kann das passiert auf allen planeten auch auf der erde und in.
Praktisch ins welt in den weltraum hinaus gelangt und was jetzt.
Die maus meteoriten sehr viel häufiger macht als meteorit zum beispiel von der venus ist die einfache tatsache dass.
Mars weiter draußen im sonnensystem ist als die
die erde das heißt wenn die auf irgendeiner beliebigen umlaufbahn sind ist die natürlich nicht stabil das größte gravitationswellen im sonnensystem ist die sonne selbst das heißt die werden so langsam aber sicher nach innen migriert und irgendwann die
kreuzen dann treffen sie auf die erde die ja auch wieder ein gravitationswellen hat und werden dann entweder durch eine direkte
der kollision oder auch dadurch eine gravitation ablenkung in richtung erde gezogen.
Natürlich sonst viele auch nicht aber die die eben der erde nahe genug kommen können kollidieren können auf der erde landen und da finden wir sie dann.
Aber wenn man jetzt so ein stein irgendwo rumliegen sie dann fällt mir da steht er nicht drauf liebe grüße vom mars sondern ich war ja auch erstmal auf die idee kommen sich das genauer anzuschauen.
Genau und dann kommt man auf die idee sich das genauer anzuschauen entweder weil man ihn hat fallen sehen nie war einer der ersten meteoriten die man überhaupt hat fallen sie ist einer der mars meteoriten
achtzehnhundert zwölf dann glaube ich mal aber legen sie mich nicht genau auf die zahl fest das heißt sie sehen den fallen und finden ihn oder sie sehen ihn zwar nicht fallen aber er hat,
diese schwarze schmelz kruste die sie gerade beschrieben haben denn beim eintritt in die erdatmosphäre wird ja auch wieder sehr viel hitze freigesetzt und dann haben sie die schmelz kruste die aber nur die aller äußersten millimeter,
und schmilzt und viel wird davon auch einfach applaudiert und kommt nie auf den boden an,
aber das was auf den boden ankommt hat halt diese wenigen millimeter glänzender schwarzer kruste außen.
Die verwittert mit der zeit und dann haben sie beim meteoriten wenig glück weil die sehen aus wie graue beiseite auf der erde und sollten sie aber dennoch finden dass der hier nicht hingehört und könnte was anderes sein dann müssen sie mit ins labor nehmen.
Sehen mit ins labor nehmen dann machen sie georg chemie dann kommt in die großen instrumente alle zum tragen denn zum einen sind einige element verhältnisse anders maus hat zum beispiel im durchschnitt im verhältnis mehr eisen.
Als magnesium das eisen magnesium verhältnis ist anders in maus gestein als es das interesse zwischen gestein ist das heißt das ist schon mal ein erster hinweis aber wirklich äh diagnostisch wie man so schön sagt,
die edel gase wo sie direkt vergleichen können diese die gase die aus diesem glas materialien kommen die beim.
Einschlag auf dem mars der diesen meteoriten quasi heraus geschleudert hat eingeschlossen worden sind mit der maß atmosphäre die in,
die walking mission gemessen hat.
Und an diesen eleganten da die in der regel mit nichts groß reagieren die sind dann halt einfach weniger unverändert dadrin und sind so ein klares zeugnis von wo es herkommt.
Das können sie messen und zwar ist es insbesondere das iso topen verhältnis ich gehe mal davon aus dass einige hörer auch schon öfters mal das wort
gehört haben das ist das hundertneunundzwanzig zehn verhältnis zum hundertzweiunddreißig zehn und das hier in der erdatmosphäre ungefähr eins ist und auf dem mars zwei komma sechs und das ist halt ein riesengroßer unterschied für
messungen den man ganz ganz eindeutig messen kann.
Das heißt man kann sich dann auch richtig sicher sein dass man hier ein stück maß in der hand hält und die ging dann alle über ihren tisch oder wie.
Damals gab es genau neun und ich hatte alle neun.
Wirklich.
Und das ist schon ein ganz besonderes gefühl denn manche sind sehr sehr selten da gibt die sind halt sehr klein und sie sind sehr selten andere sind größer inzwischen haben wir über hundert und ich habe sie lange nicht alle in der hand gehabt.
Und der rasante anstieg an meteoriten generell und dann natürlich auch den besonderen meteoriten,
kommt halt dadurch dass insbesondere in den heißen wüsten marokko und so weiter aber auch chilli leute immer mehr gehen und suchen
und wenn sie dort in diesen sand wüsten steine finden es ist zwar nicht hundert prozent sicher dass es ein meteorit ist aber die wahrscheinlichkeit ist halt extrem viel größer als wenn sie,
irgendwo in deutschland danach suchen würden und wenn sie in deutschland in basalt-adler den regionen wie sagen wir mal der eifel oder den vogelsberg nach maß meteoriten suchen,
die würden sie nie
weil die sehen halt einfach so aus wie das gestein drumherum auch es sind bei salt und da kommt jetzt wieder die geologie und die mineral energie zum tragen das sind dieselben mineralöle das sind ist dieselbe chemie mit
kleinen unterschieden aber die unterschiede sind nicht groß genug um visuell einen unterschied zu machen von daher
sie das mit dem bloßen auge draußen im gelände nicht unterscheiden außer sie sind an einer gegend wie zum beispiel in der wüste oder auch der antarktis wo man eben steine leichter,
und auch genau weiß was da vorkommt und das sehr anders ist von dem was sie eigentlich suchen.
Das heißt es gibt doch richtig so hobby stein sammler also jetzt nicht unbedingt wissenschaftler so einfach leute die so.
Hobby stein sammle auch viele ähm der lokalen bevölkerung die das dann nicht als hobby sondern das beruf betreiben.
Und dann gibt's aber auch wissenschaftliche expeditionen wenn sie in den heißen wüsten sind es viel
profis die sich darauf spezialisieren aber wenn sie in die antarktis gehen dann brauchen sie natürlich eine ganz andere logistik und da gibt es ans mit auf der amerikanischen seite es gibt aber auch die japaner und die europäer
die expeditionen machen und ganz gezielt meteoriten suchen gehen.
Hauptsächlich auf den sogenannten blue days fehlt also auf eis feldern wo das eis a kumuliert und an der oberfläche.
Wird weil dann das eis eben die meteoriten sozusagen konzentriert das eis wird zusammen geschoben an unter dem eis befindlichen.
Und wird dadurch nach oben gedrückt der wind ab plakatiert ist und.
Das einfach glatt machen.
Trägt das eis ab und die steine trägt er aber nicht ab das heißt mit der zeit geht eis verloren und steine sammeln sich an der oberfläche an und da ist dann halt sind dann halt auch sehr viele meteoriten dabei.
Interessant das heißt es gibt immer mehr zu untersuchen und das heute liegt eigentlich überall rum man muss nur.
Es gibt immer mehr zu untersuchen aber man muss natürlich gucken dass man hauptsächlich die dass man
die richtigen steine findet also ich würde jetzt nicht einfach ins internet gehen wollen und einen kaufen wo maus drauf steht denn in dem moment wo was kommerziell gemacht wird muss man halt auch äh sehr aufpassen da gibt's dann halt auch immer schwarze schafe die anzahl der e-mails die ich
bekomme wo man sagt sie haben also den größten maß meteoriten den ziel gegeben hat und ich gucke da drauf und denkt naja wenn das überhaupt
natürliches stücke stein ist dass du da fotografiert hast dann ist das dann wäre es ja schon mal ein anfang das ist halt extrem auch überall wo geld zu machen ist das das wissen wir ja.
Nur wenn man also gesichertes material haben möchte dann wendet man sich am besten an museen ins und sammlungen.
Denn wenn sie jetzt in stein finden und sagen ist das ein meteorit und dann können sie zu universitätsstadt sammlungen zu museen gehen und die leute würden ihnen das zertifizieren gegen den preis das
zehn prozent des materials oder wenn es ein sehr großer ist zehn gramm des materials in dieser sammlung verbleiben.
Und dieses material steht dann eben für die wissenschaft zur verfügung.
Und mit dem rest.
Mit den rest können sie sich auf den kaminsims stellen wenn sie wollen oder sie können in der wissenschaft spenden das kommt halt dann drauf an oder weiterverkaufen es gibt halt auch durchaus märkte wenn sie so ein zertifikat haben äh gibt es auch
börsen und markte wo man eben solche dinge in etwas gesicherten im rahmen kaufen kann und wo man eben die zertifikate auch entsprechend dann vorliegt.
Es gibt meteoriten börsen.
Mineralien börsen wo auch mit theoretiker.
Okay.
Das war ein ganz interessantes berufsfeld auf das feld bisher noch nicht so richtig gekommen jetzt habe ich den eingangs schon gesagt wir sind jetzt hier in england in milden kings einer open inversion city wie hat sich denn da hin verschlagen.
Über die abgase ich hab ich bin dann äh nach meiner mainzer zeit erstmal nach justin gegangen und habe,
mit integration beschäftigt und in der wissenschaft geht man erstmal durch eine phase wo man auf projekten ist die immer so zwei oder drei jahre lang sind das heißt
man ein bisschen durch die welt leer und wander jahre wie man es auch nennen könnte und als ich mein projekt
in den usa ist beendet hatte das kramp war so ungefähr ein halbes jahr vorher habe ich eine stelle hier gesehen die sich mit edel gassen in terroristischen steinen beschäftigt also gar nicht mehr mal aus fand das aber sehr interessant weil es da auch wieder um diese
pfade und wege ging die edel gase nehmen können sie sagten ganz richtig edel gase reagieren nicht aber sie.
Reflektieren die physikalischen bedingungen
wenn sich mineralöle bilden oder um bilden sie reflektieren die physikalischen bedingungen wenn wasser mit gestein in verbindung kommt und man kann dann sagen kommt das wasser von oben ist es also regenwasser oder ist das wasser das von unten aus dem erdmann kommt und diese dinge und da war eine sehr interessante stelle hier und da bin ich hierher gekommen und habe erstmal ein paar jahre erde gemacht
und stand bin ich zu maß zurückgekommen.
Vielleicht nochmal ein paar worte mal zur open university verlieren.
Es handelt sich um eine der größten oder die größte universität in.
Wir sind die größte universität in großbritannien wir haben aber keinen einzigen und studenten hier auf unserem campus weil wir nämlich eine fern- uni sind die deutschen sind ja mit der ferne haagen bestens vertraut wir haben dasselbe.
Das heißt unsere studenten studieren von zu hause und wir liefern die materialien durch bücher.
Internet wir haben ganz ganz viel jetzt auf dem internet in form von internetseiten wo dann videos
interaktive dinge alles was man technisch mit dem internet machen kann machen wir wir haben aber auch das sogenannte open,
wo wir.
Richtige gerät also wissenschaftliche geräte die hardware wie man so schön eng im englischen sagt haben die dann durch internetseiten bedient werden kann das heißt sie buchen sich zeit zum beispiel auf einem teleskop in teneriffa da steht das teleskop das äh könnt da können sie auch drin rumlaufen wenn sie in teneriffa sind aber
wenn sie ein student der open air university sind im gastronomie dann können sie sich dort eine stunde buchen und dann bedienen sie dieses teleskop.
Ob sie ein wissenschaftler wären der eben einen bestimmten stern untersucht und machen ihre hausaufgabe mit einem echten teleskop von ihrem sofa zu hause aus
wir simulieren auch maß missionen da haben wir eine.
Ein kleines eine hütte sag ich mal äh sechs mal vor zehn meter mit sieben tonnen sand und mal halben tonnen gestein und einem selbstgebauten rover wo wir über eine woche lang mit unseren masters studenten in mission simulieren also wir nutzen die gesamte bandbreite dessen was man machen kann im bezug auf
internet interaktiv medien video audio alles.
Trotzdem ist das ja hier ein riesen campus also stellt sich jetzt vielleicht vorher zehn ja so zwei drei baracken und eine gute internetleitung und das war dann die ganze universität dem ist ja mitnichten so also hier ist ja viel vor ort.
Viel vor ort.
Zum einen brauchen sie natürlich sehr viel mehr leute wenn sie eine video sache an die stunde für die studenten vorbereiten dann brauchen sie ins studio dann brauchen sie die leute die sich mit all der tontechnik und der film technik auskennen sieben sieben sie brauchen also.
Mehr leute als man an einem konventionellen uni braucht wo man mit dem mit der kreide oder heutzutage dem stift für die weiße wand äh als professor oder lecture einfach da rein marschiert ist wir haben also
software ingenieure und so weiter und so fort hier auf dem campus das ist die eine seite die andere seite ist wir sind auch ein forschungs- institut wir haben sehr viele laboratorien hier wir haben um zum thema mars zurück,
kommen wir hatten die rein räume hier in denen die massen spektrum meter und generell bibel zwei gebaut worden ist.
Also die der länder des,
leider nicht ganz geschafft hat also er hat schon bis auf die oberfläche geschafft aber dann.
Er hat es bis auf die maus oberfläche geschafft wir haben ihn vor zwei oder drei jahren haben wir gesehen in den highlights images,
und die vermutung von dem was was man heute noch sieht,
ist natürlich alles ein bisschen staubig geworden und sieht nicht mehr man sieht nicht mehr so die details aber das was man heute noch sieht ähm vermuten diejenigen die sich da besser auskennen als,
dass er sich nicht ganz auf gefaltet hat und weil die antenne unter den solar panels war deshalb wahrscheinlich nicht genug ja.
Die verbindung nicht erstellen konnte.
Ja aber aus solchen gescheiterten mission lernt man ja auch eine ganze menge für.
Die nächsten dann nochmal kurz bei der university ich
find das eigentlich ganz interessant ist das konzept der fern uni ist hatte glaube ich früher so ein bisschen mehr so diesen ruf mit naja dann da kommt dann irgendwie die hin die woanders nicht genommen worden sind und dann ist das so eigentlich so ein halbes studium aber ich muss sagen
heutzutage mit den möglichkeiten.
Die das netz so bietet scheint mir das fast das zukunft gewandt eure universität konzept zu sein wenn man irgendwie nicht so viel zeit darauf verwendet
ja kurz gesagt immer wieder dasselbe zu erzählen.
Für jedes neue semester sondern sich sehr viel mehr darauf
konzentriert so den dieses konzept ist das flip zu implementieren sozusagen die den tisch umzudrehen zu sagen da alles was so repetitiv es lernen ist das nennt man halt einmal auf und dann,
ist es quasi basis lernmaterial man konzentriert sich dann hier vor ort sehr viel mehr um die weiterbildung des nächsten schritt der studenten plus eben hier auch der forschung.
Ja man also da sind jetzt ganz viele themen in einem satz denn zum einen wir sind die open air university weil sie bei uns keinerlei eingangs qualifikation brauchen.
Da kommt das wird open air denn ganz wir sind ganz fest davon überzeugt dass ihre.
Ihre möglichkeiten im zarten alter von siebzehn oder achtzehn wenn man abitur macht nicht unbedingt dementsprechen was sie als mensch leisten können.
Es gibt so viele dinge die passieren in der pubertät die passieren weil die eltern gerade ihren job verloren haben man ist von so vielen dingen
abhängig gerade in dem frühen stadium wenn man in die schule geht dass es reicht vollkommen dass irgendjemand meint,
bulling betreiben zu müssen oder so und dann gehen die noten in keller und dann kriegt man eben kein abitur.
Aber das bedeutet ja nicht dass dieser mensch nicht das potenzial hat zu lernen oder er hat vielleicht
keine lust im alter von siebzehn und sieht die notwendigkeit nicht oder was,
mal passiert und wenn man das mal beiseite lässt
und dann sieht dass jemand sagen wir mal mitte zwanzig oder eben mitte dreißig oder sogar noch später feststellt.
Ich bräuchte jetzt diesen abschluss um weiterzukommen ich würde jetzt gerne,
diesen beruf ergreifen ich habe jetzt dort sagen wir mal auf der zweiten ebene gearbeitet aber ich könnte eigentlich eine ebene höher arbeiten und hätte alle die dinge aber ich bräuchte den abschluss die leute kommen dann zu uns.
Oder leute die einen beruf ergriffen haben von dem sie im zarten alter von zwanzig dachten das ist das was sie für ihr leben machen wollen und jetzt sehen mit zunehmender lebenserfahrung was sonst noch alles gibt und.
Ihren beruf wechseln wollen die kommen zu uns und das sind die besten studenten die sich so vorstellen können das sind leute die sind hoch motiviert die wissen ganz genau was sie wollen.
Und die studieren mit einem ganz fest.
Ziel und ich muss sagen es macht unheimlich viel spaß.
Ich würde es nicht unbedingt als ersatz für die universität im alter von achtzehn neunzehn empfehlen.
Denn wenn man sehr jung ist wenn ich von mir selbst ausgehe im zarten alter von neunzehn dann hat man noch nicht dieses
ziel oder einige viele haben noch nicht dieses ziel diese
diese strebst dieses ziel bewusst sein dass man so braucht und von daher ist es für mich eigentlich faszinierend zu sehen was der unterschied ist zwischen dem was wir hier eine.
University also eine universität wo sie ins gebäude reingehen und im gebäude mit dem lecture vorne lernen
sehr strukturiert sehr auch zeitlich strukturiert weil die die veranstaltung findet eben um zehn uhr morgens statt am montag und das ist wenn sie das ist die
eben mathematik machen
im vergleich zu berufsbegleitende studium wie wir es machen für leute die entweder ein beruf haben oder äh familiäre verpflichtungen die sich ihre zeit selbst einteilen dass das ist was ganz anderes und ich denke mal
das sollte parallel existieren weil es ist nicht austauschbar auf der anderen seite wenn sie sagen dass repetitiv lernen wir haben tutoren unsere
gruppen sind sagen wir mal geologie studiert zurzeit ungefähr zweihundert leute mit uns im zwei,
ja das ist also drittes viertes semester
und ähm dass diese zweihundert leute sind in gruppen zu zwanzig aufgeteilt und haben ihren toter und der total ist für die da mit dem reden die regelmäßig aber eben nicht regelmäßig um montags früh um zehn sondern äh meistens abends.
Und am wochenende und dann aber auch über äh medien wo man es nicht unbedingt zeitgleich machen muss also e-mail.
Video nachrichten und solche sachen.
Wir nehmen auch alles auf was wir machen also wenn ich jetzt 'ne live-sendung sozusagen mache mit den studenten für eine stunde irgendwo an einem samstagabend oder was das wird
immer aufgenommen das können sie sich immer auch noch später anhören da gibt's immer noch später die möglichkeit fragen zu stellen.
Ja das hat ja auch so ein paar inklusive aspekte also was was ich allein erziehende,
et cetera also einfach leute die vielleicht so im normalen universität betrieb so gar nicht folgen könnten,
oder zumindest nur unter größeren anstrengungen oder einschränkungen in ihrem leben haben natürlich von so einem konzept auch etwas.
Ja und das ist auch warum ich so gerne hier bin weil ich denke der zweite bildungsweg ist genauso wichtig wie der erste bildungsweg.
So das heißt diese diese größe macht sich hier an der zahl der studenten fest.
Und hier auf dem campus haben wir also gar keine der derjenigen die noch vor dem diplom oder master stehen wen wir hier auf dem campus haben sind die doktoranden denn wir sind ein forschungs- institut wir haben sehr sehr viele labore ähm
wir haben sabor instrumente
gebaut werden die dann irgendwas in der weltraum forschung zu tun haben und auch andere planeten kometen satelliten und so weiter bestücken aber wir haben auch forschungslabor der geo wissenschaften und weiter heraus aus meinem fachbereich,
ingenieure und alles was man sich eben an der universität so vorstellt.
Also hier wird auch viel raumfahrt gebaut viele instrumente gebaut und von daher ist das eigentlich auch ein vitaler raumfahrt standort kann man sagen.
Sozusagen ja ich hab's zwar so noch nicht gesehen aber es ist auch nicht falsch.
Ja dann kommen wir doch mal wieder ein bisschen zurück zum zum maß und der explotion also.
Lange zurück ist aber schon gehört prinzip mal so ein bisschen die geschichte aufrollt der underground explotion.
Darum geht es uns ja hier im wesentlichen muss man den siebziger jahren anfangen mit dieser walking mission.
Die mission haben wir ja schon erwähnt mit den maß meteoriten in zusammenhang walking war eine,
sehr ambitionierte mission karl sagen
ist ja der große name und für mich auch einer der helden weil er nicht nur eine tolle mission da aufgestellt hat sondern weil er auch der erste war
dem ist wichtig war dass nicht nur im elfenbein turm zu machen sondern rauszugehen und den leuten zu erzählen was eigentlich passiert und warum das so faszinierend ist,
keine dummen fragen kommt eigentlich von ihm und das finde ich also total wichtig auch.
Muss man sagen ist auch ein großer wissenschaftskommunikation tor geworden nicht nur wissenschaftler
cosmos diese fernsehserie die er da produziert hat finde ich es immer noch einer der großartigsten einführung zum verständnis des universums.
Sehr interessant und ich glaube auch der begriff dieses paypal blut dort zu dieser unbedeutende kleine blaue punkt wenn man mal,
mit einer was war das von der mission aufgenommen das foto quasi von der erde wo aber eben wirklich nicht sehr viel mehr übrig ist als der kleine
blaue punkt das war dann auch eine interessante philosophische betrachtung um sich mal selber darüber klar zu werden wo wir eigentlich sind und welche rolle wir so im universum spielen.
Ja er ist regelmäßig wenn man so die frage gestellt kriegt wenn du drei leute zum dinner einladen könntest tot oder lebendig wäre wäre dass er ist immer der erste auf meiner liste.
Eine der sachen ja ich hätte ihn gerne kennengelernt.
Okay aber er hat dann sozusagen erheblich an dieser mission mitgearbeitet.
Ja und walking war halt eine astro biologie mission bevor das wort astro biologie so in dem sinne ähm.
Gegründet war sozusagen
die hatten eben instrumente mit denen sie die biologie chemie untersuchung können aber sie hatten halt auch instrumente mit denen sie nachweisen versuchen wollte.
Leben auf dem mars gibt das problem der walking mission war dass man noch so wenig wusste über den mars.
Deshalb viele der ergebnisse eben nicht interpretiert werden konnten oder nicht eindeutig interpretiert werden kann.
Es gab zwei sondern bikini eins ist fünfundsiebzig.
Gestartet sechsundsiebzig dort.
In der lander das waren übernommen arbeit oder war das auch ein landesweiten landtag genau und,
ja dann ging zwei kurz danach gestartet und es war sozusagen ja nicht nur die erste wirklich richtige mission zum maßnahmen eben auch gleich erfolgreich.
Die wenn man sich die geschichte der maß mission anschaut die russen leider immer extrem betroffen von den felix sind amerikaner ist erstaunlich viel gelungen muss man sagen.
Damit ging es im prinzip los das heißt vor den siebziger jahren muss man eigentlich herzlich wenig und durch die walking mission was wusste man dann.
Man musste dann
die zusammensetzung man wusste auch dass man man hatte die ersten bilder tatsächlich von der oberfläche denn wenn man noch ein paar schritte zurückgeht und sieht mit den fingern mit den marina missionen,
dann hat man halt die auflösung aus dem orbit da sieht man gerade mal ein paar krater mit der zunehmenden aus auflösung den jüngeren marina missionen hat man dann auch gesehen dass es eben fluss bette gibt
und so aber erst nachdem man wirklich auf der oberfläche war konnte man halt sehen
wie sieht 's dort aus mit mit der auflösung mit der man auch hier auf der erde ein bild machen könnte
sehen was die umweltbedingungen sind man hat auch ähm ganz wichtig die atmosphäre gemessen und erforscht.
Denn nur dadurch dass man eben die maus atmosphäre ihr die zusammensetzung windgeschwindigkeiten und alle diese dinge die für uns so mit dem,
und wetterdienst so selbstverständlich sind,
erforscht hat konnte man kann man natürlich auch die umwelt einschätzen mit der man es doch zu tun hat und eben die georg chemie und dann äh die ähm.
Die experimente die eben sich mit dem leben beschäftigt haben wo man in in einer serie von drei in verschiedenen versuchen versucht hat herauszufinden ob irgendetwas
reagiert und die,
die nährstoffe die man anbietet verdaut.
Heutzutage ist wohl die allgemeine meinung,
dass die partei rate waren also in organische substanzen
zu der reaktion beigetragen hat die man gemessen hat aber,
sicher kann man natürlich nicht sein aber von dem stand den wir heute haben auch mit,
phoenix lander mischen die auch wieder die park gefunden hat hat park gefunden ist wohl dass das was die reaktion ausgelöst hat,
die die nährstoffe die die dort in diesem in diesem projekt zu uns gefäße drin waren,
eben mit den reagiert hat und die so tope freigesetzt hat die dann gemessen worden sind.
Also walking hat sozusagen die basis gelegt und man hatte jetzt das erste mal eine konkrete vorstellung,
davon womit man es eigentlich zu tun hat.
Und das hat ja dann im prinzip auch
diese ja diese lange liste mittlerweile von boden missionen ausgelöst oder dann sozusagen begründet
die ja dann vor allem von den amerikanern halt extrem erfolgreich durchgeführt worden und die passende mission war dann im prinzip schon die nächste.
War der erste robert.
Und das war im grunde genommen eine technologie demonstration denn wenn man raumfahrt betreibt und das beste beispiel dafür ist immer apollo dann möchte man jeden schritt einzeln erstmal üben und sehen dass es auch.
Und man möchte
fünfzehn schritte gleichzeitig machen und die apollo mission wenn man dadurch geht äh und sieht in wie systematisch die jeden weiteren schritt geübt haben in der apollo mission und dann gesehen haben
was die ergebnisse sind bevor sie den nächsten schritt gemacht haben zeigt eigentlich wie es am,
geht und die amerikaner haben das für die lande mission genauso gemacht den ersten rover party-freunde
im grunde genommen die technologie demonstration aber er hatte das instrument und natürlich kameras.
Kameras sind auch immer für den geologie wissenschaftliche daten mit denen man dann eben mehr und auch von einer anderen stelle vom aus gelernt hat.
Was
was hat dann die passende mission herausgefunden also war dann die instrumente so sehr waren jetzt sehr viel andere instrumente noch mit an bord oder ist es im wesentlichen eigentlich die möglichkeit sich auf dem mars bewegen
können und an verschiedenen stellen proben zu nehmen oder urlaub sehr baff also.
In der europa war im hauptsächlich eben die technologie demonstration der lander hatte einige instrumente ich meine sie fliegen nicht zum mars ohne eine wetterstationen mitzunehmen zum beispiel aber das wichtige dass was für die weiterentwicklung
der maß missionen wichtig war war dass man eben den kleinen rover hatte,
dass der auch ein instrument drauf hatte dass dass man gelernt hat wie man sich in dem.
Bewegen kann dass man gesehen hat dass es eben geht und die ingenieure seite ist ja immer das wichtigste denn wenn sie kein instrument haben dass sich bewegt.
Dass die dinge durchführen kann die sie durchführen wollen dann brauchen sie mit der wissenschaft nicht anzufangen da haben sie nämlich keine da.
Das heißt.
Wissenschaftlich vielleicht die wichtigste erkenntnis war dass der staub der auf maß in durch die atmosphäre regelmäßig immer wieder verteilt wird,
überall allgegenwärtig ist und dass viele der messungen die vom instrument auf,
gemacht worden sind eine starke komponente von diesem staub
mit drauf hatten und das ist halt auch ein grund warum
die nachfolgenden missionen eigentlich alle irgendwas haben womit sie den staub von der oberfläche entfernen können.
Das tool oder die brush je nachdem welche mission sie jetzt neben rock tool wäre das instrument,
die maß experience over spirit and opportunity haben auf dem robert robert,
es eine meine bürste.
Immer wieder ganz einfache lösung funktioniert am besten.
Ihr ja wenn sie sie wollen so wenig wie möglich bewegliche teile wenn sie ein instrument bauen wo sie nicht hin können und reparieren gehen können.
Ja
Also der der rover auf im rahmen der parfüm mission das war ja schon so prinzip.
So sechs räder apparat bestand im wesentlichen so oben aus einer großen aus dem großen solar panel wo dann die ganzen instrumente darunter waren,
der konnte also im wesentlichen erstmal rumfahren.
Der konto rumfahren und er konnte wie gesagt die steinchen nehmen das war das wichtigste und wenn sie sich das.
Von einem test standpunkt aus angucken
in dem moment wo sie wissenschaftler und ingenieure zusammenarbeiten lassen wissenschaftler haben bestimmte ziele die von dem.
Bestimmt sind was wir sehen.
Wenn wir steine sehen die überall vorkommen dann wollen wir natürlich wissen welche zusammensetzung die haben aber dann ist plötzlich einer der sieht anders aus dann wollen wir natürlich wissen wie der sich auch chemisch unterscheidet das heißt
uns interessiert nicht so sehr
die frage ist der pfad den wir da hinfahren wollen der sicherst mögliche den wir jetzt fahren können sondern wir denken nach gewissen zielen
ingenieure natürlich schauen und auch zu vollkommen zu recht sehr viel mehr nach sicherheit nach der befahrbar kalt eines unter grundes und solchen dingen und dieses zusammenspiel muss man auch erstmal lernen.
Wie viel kann ich als wissenschaftler erwarten von so einem instrument wieviel können die ingenieure das was sie eigentlich als grenzen gesetzt haben so ein bisschen ausweiten wie sicher werden die sich mit der zeit eine mission mit diesen dingen das sind halt fragen die im laufe der zeit.
Wickelt werden und wo es wichtig ist dass auch erfahrung gesammelt wird.
Und das kann man natürlich zum teil hier auf der erde machen mit mission simulationen wo man das kann man zum teil auch insbesondere wenn es um die ingenieur fragen geht in sogenannten maus ja zu machen wo man also bedingungen simulieren kann und dann äh
ein equity valentin instrument natürlich sehr viel herrscherin tests aussetzen kann als dass sie das
je auf einem anderen planeten machen würden da gibt's also viele viele möglichkeiten am dieses zusammenspiel ist das erste mal mit dem trainer gemacht worden.
Und was war so die großen errungenschaften immer das war ja noch zu einer zeit als sie nicht unmittelbar selber mit den projekten beschäftigt waren sondern das quasi noch so parallel liefert hat man da so mitbekommen was waren so die.
Die weiteren erkenntnisse die jetzt aus dem aus dieser mission hervor kam.
Für mich war es wirklich die gestalt zusammensetzung ich hab damals dann sehr bald auch angefangen mich mit den mars meteoriten zu beschäftigen und die gestein zusammensetzen
die georg chemie das war für mich persönlich die große,
von dem europa und,
aber auch das instrument ist am max bank institut gebaut worden
und auf eine ganz persönliche ebene zum ersten mal hautnah mitzubekommen weil ich eben kollegen hatte mit denen ich im büro geteilt habe und die dann auch,
gearbeitet haben wie so was abläuft die begeisterung zu sehen zu zu fühlen wie sich das anfühlt wenn man ein bild.
Allerersten mal hier auf der erde sieht und man einer von zehn leuten ist sie das jetzt gerade zum,
mal sehen das ist eigentlich etwas dass man.
So nur mit der expo ration neuer kontinente oder vielleicht heutzutage der mit oder sowas untersee,
petitionen vergleichen kann.
Aber man hat mal ist ja auch nicht mehr ganz ergebnisoffen also man will ja sozusagen hin auch um und er hat ja auch bestimmte dinge die man überprüfen möchte so also was war sozusagen das
primäre ziel klar also die grundsätzliche grundsätzliche zusammensetzung von allem um überhaupt erstmal zu,
und auch um dann eben solche maß methode
einordnen zu können und man beweisen zu können dass es halt auch wirklich welche sind aber was ja immer eine große rolle gespielt hat war also die frage die suche nach dem.
Wasser auf dem planeten.
Und das kommt daher dass eine der fundamentalen fragen eben die frage ist sind wir alleine oder gibt es noch irgendwo anders als auf der erde leben und um nach sowas zu suchen muss man sich natürlich,
mal einen anfang setzen und da war der anfang den die nasa sich gesetzt hat follower water,
folge dem wasser weil wir wissen von leben auf der erde das wasser absolut notwendig ist wenn sie in die.
Wüsten hier auf der erde gehen dann gibt,
ganz ganz wenig nur an pflanzen und tieren das dort existieren kann und die haben strategien wie sie wasser speichern wie wasser freie zeiten überstehen wenn man das jetzt auf den maus überträgt wo man eben nicht wusste oder nur von den,
von dem was man wusste gibt's gar kein wasser wir wissen heute dass es teilweise regionen gibt wo es ein kleines bisschen oberflächen wasser auch heute noch geben könnte in.
Zeiten die so genannten recruiting sloppy aber das wusste man damals alles ja noch nicht das heißt die frage war hat es jemals
fließendes wasser auf der maß oberfläche gegeben oder,
ist es nur in der im untergrund des maß oder vielleicht überhaupt
nicht wirklich so wie auf dem mond also das sind alles fragen,
man sich von anfang an gestellt hat die eben schon
bei marina eigentlich bei den satelliten missionen
wichtig waren und dann mit dem mit allen missionen die äh auf dem mars landen auch immer wichtiger geworden sind
die fragen werden komplexer jeder je näher wir uns dagegen wart nähern denn leben ist ja nicht nur von wasser abhängig sie brauchen auch organische materialien sie brauchen auch an die chemie im ganzen ähm,
jeder weiß es essentielle elemente in körper braucht kalzium im körper braucht magnesium bakterien genauso und sind diese dinge alle vorhanden jeder hat schon mal gehört dass es elemente gibt
ich sage nur mal aussehen aber auch zum beispiel kupfer die als antje
biotec wirken können die lebens feindliche sind man muss die gesamt zusammen den gesamt zusammenhang verstehen ganz am anfang war es aber das wasser.
Und die frage können wir nachweisen dass es dort jemals wasser gegeben hat denn wenn sie eine mission schicken wollen die tatsächlich nach leben sucht oder nach spuren vergangenen lebens sucht.
Wenn sie wissen dass dort nie wasser war braucht man im prinzip erstmal nicht anzufangen zu suchen
denn sie müssen es irgendwie eingrenzen und deshalb grenzt man es erstmal ein auf leben wie wir es kennen
und von dort dann sucht man nach bedingungen wo es vorgefallen bekommen hätte sein können um dann missionen zu schicken
wie jetzt zum beispiel die thomas mission die nächstes jahr fliegen wird und bohren wird.
Um nach den sogenannten biomarkt also nach spuren vergangenen lebens zu suchen.
Und hat schon an hinweise liefern können für die frage wasser.
Ich
ich bin mir so nicht ganz sicher im moment wenn ich ehrlich bin denn die der wirkliche,
durchbruch der sich mir als außenstehender.
So eingeprägt hat sind die blueberry s und sind die sachen die die maße explosion robers gefunden haben.
Da darf hat das für mich wirklich angefangen zu sagen ihr habt das ist wie auf der erde und ja wir haben hydro tamal systeme wir haben wasser gestein wechselwirkung wir haben situation die mit von wasser abhängig ist und so weiter.
Genau damit wären wir dann sozusagen schon bei der nächsten mission und die war ja dann auch sehr viel wie soll ich sagen
medienwirksam auf jeden fall also das äh ich erinnere mich selber noch sehr gut daran als die mission gestartet ist also maß explosion
rover ist die mission ja dann gleich mit zwei rowan gestartet ist birgit und opportunity heute verhältnismäßig.
Bekannt weil einfach extrem erfolgreiche missionen man dachte glaube ich oder ursprünglich mal glaube ich so davon ausgegangen naja wenn die dinger vierzehn tage lang oder oder einen monat neunundneunzig tage ok neunzig tage,
schon richtig erzählt also neunzig tage halten so dann ist das ziel irgendwie erreicht aber am ende waren's.
Dreizehn nein sechzehn jahre.
Ja der spirit etwas kürzer als
genaue zahlen kann ich ihnen nicht sagen aber äh was ich ganz gerne sage wenn ich vorträge halte ähm wenn neunzig tage war die garantie zeit
und spätestens als zehn jahre erreicht waren kann man dann sagen wenn alle unsere autos so lange halten würden wären wir alle mit einer lissy unterwegs.
Ja also das ist äh genau also spirit hat bis bis zweitausendelf.
Gehalten das ist natürlich irgendwie wirklich irre.
Und opportunity bis letztes jahr glaube.
Letztes jahr war der große sand sturm war.
Also was was war jetzt so sein die bis also wie wie inwiefern waren denn jetzt diese mission besser ausgestattet oder anders ausgestattet als,
der vorgänger.
Die missionen waren wissenschafts mission und nicht ingenieur missionen natürlich hat
wie der name der gesamte mission paar feinde auch sagt den weg bereitet aber die mission war insofern anders als dass sie keine ingenieur mission von der nase initiiert war sondern wir hatten einen sogenannten prinzip investigative,
professor steve von der seine mission beantragt und gebaut hat
um das thema follower water wir wollen sehen was die georg chemie ist war wasser.
Mitbeteiligt und hat eben mit den kameras mit den spektral kameras aber auch wieder dem instrument 'ne ganze reihe instrumente gehabt die.
Die chemie und die gesamtheit der der landschaft eben untersuchung konnten und,
hatten eben sehr viel glück dass europa auch so extrem lange gehalten haben.
Und haben dann sowohl vom spirit als auch vom opportunity
diverse gestein formationen diverse chemie gefunden die ganz,
eindeutig dafür spricht dass eben was er gestein wechselwirkung stattgefunden haben das heißt
diese mission sind für mich persönlich diejenigen die mir zum ersten mal klar gemacht haben wie.
Wie viele gemeinsamkeiten es gibt zwischen mars und der erde und
wie übertragbar aber dann auch wieder nicht übertragbar unsere erkenntnisse die wir hier auf der erde sammeln über das leben auf der erde auf den mars wären.
Und übertragbar sind sie was die steine angeht wir haben bei salzige steine maß hat ein bisschen mehr eisen das habe ich vorhin
im zusammenhang mit dem meteoriten schon mal gesagt aber im.
Es sind nach wie vor bei salzige steine sie haben eisen zwei plus das dann o x ignoriert werden kann und als
und äh alle situationen und reduktion prozesse sind immer vorteilhaft für
leben wenn man jetzt auf das thema zurückkommt und eröffnen da möglichkeiten wir haben also wasser wir haben in redoxpotential wir haben etwas voss vor was man ja auch braucht calcium magnesium und so weiter und so fort diese parallelen
aber dann auch wieder ganz krasse unterschiede unsere erdatmosphäre hat sauerstoff die maß atmosphäre hat praktisch keinen sauerstoff wir haben eine.
Stickstoff atmosphäre mars hat eine c c o zwei atmosphäre also es gibt dann auch wieder unterschiede mit denen man rechnen muss und die man dann wiederum nur im labor simulieren kann weil eben die erde dann doch wieder anders ist und,
diese gemeinsamkeiten und unterschiede das ist wirklich das was die,
spirit und opportunity mission für mich ganz persönlich herausgearbeitet haben.
Was ich nicht verstanden habe wie hat man das wasser gefunden ohne das wasser zu finden also man hat sich sie gestein angeschaut und was dann daran entdeckt.
Da kommen wir jetzt wieder zur mineral energie zurück denn im insofern als das.
Gewisse mineralöle entstehen wenn wasser und gestein miteinander in verbindung kommen fangen wir mal.
Zum beispiel.
Fangen wir mal mit einem ganz einfachen beispiel an salz sehen wenn sie wenn sie wasser haben und das immer weiter ein dampfen entstehen ganz bestimmte
ab folgen da kriegen sie erst lori de und dann promis spirit hat ich glaube es war im viktoria krater ein profil gemessen wo man diese abfolge gesehen hat.
Und äh gerade promille und gloria rede können sie.
Allerbesten durch ein dampfen des wasser sie voneinander separieren das heißt hier haben sie diese diese typische abfolge wo man eine parallele herstellen kann man kann aber auch andere mineralöle angucken.
Gibt's gibt's nicht eine andere erklärung mit dir das hätte auch passieren können oder ist das schon so ein ist das schon so so eine heiße.
Das ist eine sehr sehr heiße spur das ist eine sehr sehr heiße spur die.
Im prinzip anders nicht zu erklären ist andere heiße spuren sind mineral die wasser in ihrer struktur eingebaut haben nehmen sie ton mineralöle.
Die haben wasser als eine oha gruppe in ihrer struktur eingebaut.
Sie können sie nicht machen wenn sie kein wasser haben denn sie können noch was einbauen was sie auch haben und ist diese gruppen die kann man halt.
Sehr gut auch sehen das heißt nicht nur dort wo man gerade eben steht mit seinem rover sondern auch in der weiteren umgebung oder sogar von satelliten aus beobachten.
Und dann sehen sie ton mineralöle sie sehen aber auch soll fahrte auch wieder eine mineral gruppe die immer nur in zusammenhang mit wasser entsteht und dann auch wiederum wasser einbaut in die struktur das heißt,
von dem was wir über mineral entstehung wissen.
Sind mineralöle dort zu finden die sich ausschließlich in wasser gestein wechselwirkung oder durch eine lösung von wasser bilden können.
Und das ist im prinzip denn an einer der nachweise dass wir wasser auf der maß oberfläche hatten.
Das heißt man hat das wasser erstmal nicht selber gefunden man hat aber eindeutige spuren gefunden dass es mal da gewesen sein muss weil sonst eben bestimmte mineralöle so nicht hätten existieren können.
Und das ist natürlich auch ganz wichtig die satelliten hier ins spiel zu bringen denn die geomantie logi e äh also die betrachtung der oberfläche eines planeten,
mindestens genauso wichtig denn wenn sie von der auf einem planeten oberfläche schauen dann sehen sie zum beispiel fluß täler.
Mit der ganz typischen meer frierende oder
zeigten moralphilosophie und das kennen sie von der erde die bedingungen wann die mehr integrieren und wann die sich vor zweigen und können das dann sie müssen immer für die schwerkraft.
Korrigieren aber können das dann übertragen und auf die art und weise kann man also vom satelliten,
beispielsweise fluß täler feststellen man kann äh erosion spuren feststellen wenn man jetzt landet.
Eben sich die oberfläche von einem von einem.
Form die gelandet ist anschaut rover oder lander dann kann man diese,
auch sehen eine der ersten erkenntnisse von curiosity waren diese kondome rate die wir gefunden haben einfach in bildern gesehen haben und uns dann ausrechnen konnten wie ein fluss der die transportiert hat hätte aussehen müssen,
man hat also die moto logi e zusammen mit der georg chemie und was ich ganz wichtig finde ist zu betonen dass niemals.
Einziger hinweis alleine,
der beweis ist sondern nur der zusammenhang viele verschiedene dieser indizien kann uns letzten endes bestätigen was geschehen ist oder auch nicht.
Was war denn die lande orte von spirit und opportunity gut gewählt.
Ja
ich denke schon es waren zwei sehr verschiedene lande orte natürlich für spirit hatte man sich erhofft dass man in einem großen see ein getrockneten seebad oder irgendwas landet und seitdem ente findet was man erstmal nicht gefunden hat aber das ist expo ration ich mein wenn man 's vorher gewusst hätte.
Es war halt noch keiner da das so ist das nun mal aber es,
hat halt unheimlich viele,
wunderbare erkenntnisse gehabt die sind in die hass bin hills hoch geklettert und haben dort ins insbesondere um home herum.
Sehr viele indizien gefunden für hypothek male,
mineral also mineralöle die mit wässern die aus der mehr aus der
tiefe kommen entstehen die haben die ablagerungen gefunden die haben karbonat gefunden also eine ganze weite bandbreite verschiedene indizien von verschiedenen wasser gestein wechselwirkung.
Und das ist halt grade weil es auch so divers ist hoch spannend.
Der opportunity der ist eben auch das ist sehr sehr weit gefahren und die letzte große erkenntnisse in marathon valley und
in dem bereich war eben dass wir dort ein echtes.
Impakt generiert das hydro tamara system haben also wir haben uns eingangs unterhalten wie im park krater entstehen
wenn der staub sich dann gesetzt hat haben sie natürlich immer noch die ganze energie in dem untergrund drin heiße gesteinigt geschmolzene steine und dann kann sich ähnlich wie äh um volkan herum
ein hydro tamal system ausbilden wo heißes wasser durch,
untergrund zirkulieren und mineral gestein wechselwirkung verursacht
genau das haben die halt dort auch gefunden das war so die letzte große erkenntnis von opportunity,
die aber auch extrem wichtig war denn wir haben diese sachen aus dem orbit beobachtet wir satelliten haben verschiedene mineralöle gesehen aber vom von dem satelliten fehlt ihnen der direkte geologisch e zusammenhang den der feld theologe vor ort
was so ein rover letztlich ist eben herstellen kann.
Ich hab grade mal so geguckt ist ja auch sehr schön man kann ja mit google oder sich auf den mars anschauen und dann auch die ganzen reise routen der rosa nachschlagen das ist ja eigentlich sehr schön,
benennt eigentlich diese ganzen krater dann immer mit so hübschen namen.
Letztlich ist es die eu die namen wirklich bestätigt es gibt
zwei ebenen wenn sie anfangen irgendwo sich im gelände zu bewegen und viele leute die selben bilder ansehen dann brauchen sie einen moment
tour und stein eins zwei drei funktioniert nur wenn sie nur fünf stück haben aber in den nochmal eine landschaft hat eben sehr viel mögliche ziele der untersuchung das heißt missionen
geben sich regeln wie einfach.
Ziele benannt werden und das kann in eine kleine sandbühne sein das kann ein einzelner stein sein das kann ein größerer,
gestein zu rücken sein auf curiosity haben wir eine karte erstellt,
am anfang die in quadranten unterteilt war und die quadranten haben einen namen und dieser name,
von irgendwoher geografisch gesehen auf der
erde zum beispiel sind wir momentan im sogenannten tori don quadrat für die curiosity mission das heißt unsere namen momentan kommen von geografischen namen aus schottland
und wir haben eine lange liste und nach der wir dann eben dinge benannt weil sie brauchen diese namen menschen sind nicht gut nennt sich lange mehr stelligen nummern zu merken.
Er ist auch langweilig an vielen drückt sich ja auch eine gewisse kultur aus.
Ja also eine erstaunliche strecke und man sieht halt wie sehr man dann irgendwie zielgerichtet auf insbesondere die hohen strukturen aus war oder eben auf die karte je nachdem was auf dem viral war.
Ja und das ist der grund dafür ist dass geologie gegen sogenannte ausschüsse brauchen wenn sie über eine flache landschaft fahren dann sehen sie nicht unbedingt den untergrund.
Aber wenn sie in in dieser landschaft brüche haben
also zum beispiel eine krater wand oder wenn sie hier auf der erde unterwegs,
sind wir gerade eine straße neu gebaut wird dann wird dann,
stehen auf schlüsse in den untergrund wo man eben nicht nur die zweidimensional ale oberflächen struktur sehen kann sonne die dritte dimension in den untergrund und so was haben sie im gebirge
wo sie sehr gerechte wände haben und so was haben sie in kratzern wo eben ihnen sozusagen jemand ein loch frei kostenfrei.
Gebohrt hat geschaufelt hatte wie man sagen möchte.
Da selber was zu bord sieht man grade ist gar nicht so einfach äh auf dem mars die maß insights mission versucht hier gerade mit so einem kleinen hämmerchen und bora in die erde reinzukommen um dort einmal in der tiefe dinge messen zu können aber das gestaltet sich,
schwierig.
Das gestaltet sich momentan sehr schwierig und das einzige was ich
zu wirklich sagen kann ist dass ich die luft anhalten und meine und die daumen.
Die das schaffen denn den wärme fluss zu messen was diese sondern eigentlich vorher,
wäre eine der ganz großen meilensteine in der maß forschung warum es nicht gemacht worden ist bisher sehen wir gerade es ist nämlich gar nicht so einfach.
Ja da ist alles ziemlich schwierig was war denn ihre rolle bei spirit und opportunity.
Da sozusagen also ich habe für spirit and opportunity war ich mit der mission selbst nicht beteiligt ich hab allerdings während ich in,
war sehr viel von den daten verwendet und meine eigene forschung auf diesen daten.
Gebaut das gute bei nasa missionen ist dass alle daten spätestens nach sechs monaten auf der
planet data system gegeben werden und sind für jeden zugänglich als einzige was sie brauchen ist eine funktionsfähige e-mail-adresse,
und dann können sie sich auf dieses planeten data system einloggen und dann können sie die mission verfolgen noch in weit größeren.
Teil als sie das jetzt auf google oft können und können von jedem jedem messwert der je genommen worden ist sich selbst.
Eben ansehen und auch für ihre eigene forschung weiterverwenden und das hab ich halt genutzt und hab einige meiner äh wasser gestein modelle
die ich als mineral loge eben mir erstellt habe die hab ich mit diesen daten gemacht und es ist eine sehr sehr schöne quelle weil die eben so lange unterwegs waren so viele verschiedene dinge
untersucht haben ist eine wunderbare quelle für geologisch daten auf maus.
War das dann schon zur zeit hier auf der open society oder noch feuer.
Das war vorher ich war zwei jahre in husten am institut da habe ich das gemacht ähm zusammen mit doktor david der hatte das projekt ein geworben und ich habe da als sogenannter post stock gearbeitet.
So aber jetzt wird's ernst.
Nach dem opportunity so erfolgreich waren vieles der nasa glaube ich etwas leichter gleich die nächste mission nicht nur aufzulegen sondern auch gleich so richtig super das heißt zu planen.
Das maß science laboratory oder eigentlich alles bisschen besser bekannt unter dem mitnehmen des robers curiosity.
Das
war dann schon ein erheblicher schritt weil man jetzt nicht so ein vergleichsweise kleinen minirock hatte der mit kleinen rädern durch die gegend rollt sondern ich glaube ich ja wenig leute klammern ist das so dieser
ja dieses laboratory wie's ja offiziell eigentlich heißt also dieser rover ist ja so in der größenordnung eines weiß nicht vw golf größer sogar noch.
Nehmen wir ungefähr ja also der rover ist eine tonne schwer und der mast ist zwei meter hoch ungefähr.
Tonnen schwer bei uns wenn er hier rumsteht.
Und äh zwei meter hoch ungefähr und ist.
Hat viele unterschiede aber auch wiederum viele gemeinsamkeiten zu spirit opportunity die gemeinsamkeiten ist der geologie.
Denn wir haben das instrument wieder wir haben kameras wir haben kameras die spektral analyse machen.
Aber nicht dasselbe instrument sondern schon eine weiterentwicklung.
Ein neues ein neues das instrument ist an und für sich ein sehr robustes instrument das hervorragend funktioniert und ähm man ändert nur die dinge die man ändern muss entweder weil man eine weiterentwicklung
braucht
oder weil man irgendwas festgestellt hat dass nicht so funktioniert also entweder sie brauchen eine weiterentwicklung aus wissenschaftlichen gründen aber das instrument ist eines der instrumente von dem wir ganz genau wissen
wie es funktioniert wie die daten zu.
Sind es ist sozusagen eine konstante in den ganzen und.
Das hat man ja selten in der raumfahrt.
Das hat man selten weil ganz viel natürlich auch die weiterentwicklung dass das weitere erforschen nicht
nur der wissenschaftlichen sondern auch der technologischen seite von seiten der ingenieure immer eine große rolle spielt,
und auch eine berechtigte rolle spielt denn wenn wir uns weiterentwickeln wollen dann müssen wir die grenzen immer austesten und versuchen zu
erweitern aber wenn man natürlich ein instrument hat dass man als konstante verwenden kann dann macht das die dinge leichter und auch effizienter
und das marc ins laboratory das hat halt zum ziel gehabt auch wieder die geologie der umgebung zu untersuchen
es hat zum ziel gehabt.
Also die bewohnbar kalt aber wenn ich jetzt bewohnbar zeit sage dann meine ich für mikroorganismen.
Nicht für komplexere organismus diese des geld grad das zu untersuchen und auch zukünftige mission vorzubereiten.
Warum hat man den gel quarter als ziel genommen.
Lande stellen werden immer in einem komplexen verfahren ausgesucht das heißt jahre bevor die mission überhaupt startet
gibt es einen aufruf an die wissenschaftliche gemeinde zu sagen wir wollen einen rover landen wo sollen wir das tun und dann finden workshops statt in denen,
möglichkeiten vorgestellt ausgearbeitet und dann auch wieder ausgeschlossen werden das ganze ist im letzten ende ein demokratischer
an denen dann einen vorschlag meistens in einer priorität
liste von drei oder vier landes stellen an die nase weitergegeben wird.
Und die nasa prüft die dann alle denn das
aller allerwichtigste ist die sicherheit des instruments wenn man nicht garantieren kann dass man irgendwo um sicher landen kann,
dann braucht man gar nicht erst zu fliegen denn wenn man
michael ankommt dann war's das mit der mission von daher ist das ingenieur wesen und die betrachtung des ausgesuchten standortes halt,
extrem wichtig natürlich gibt's einschränkungen schon vorher man kennt sein landeslisten man weiß auf welcher höhe man landen kann man weiß wo auf dem planeten im bezug auf ähm.
Dem den breiten und lenkrad man landen kann man weiß.
Geologie wo möchte man landes in dem fall waren dass die.
Die sogenannten joachim
wo man landen wollte man weiß wo die vorkommen da gibt es karten man weiß äh die höhe man könnte also nie auf dem olympus monz landen weil dort die luft so dünn ist dass man eben im moment mit den gängigen landes system nicht thailand kommen würde das heißt alle diese dinge werden in karten dargestellt dann bleibt ein teil des maß übrig und den
sich die wissenschaftliche gemeinde an und sagt dort möchten wir hin.
Dann aber müssen wir auch noch gucken wie sie das gelände im einzelnen aus dann kommt das highlights instrument am auf maß express wieder zum tragen wie groß ist die raue seit der oberfläche wie viele gesteinsbrocken liegen rum
können wir mit dem was wir dort landen wollen an dieser stelle sicher landen und.
Also highlights dieses drei erfassung also die.
Kamera die resolution experiment also die kamera die eben sehr kleine strukturen auch erkennen kann.
Durch die komposition dann eben so ein richtiges dreidimensionalen sehr feines modell der oberfläche auch erstellt werden konnte.
Und das braucht man halt denn curiosity hatte in radar und konnte ihn immer relativ kleinen raum landen deshalb konnten wir auch neben diesem sechs kilometer hohen berg job,
realismus landen also dem zentralen,
im krater aber die die grundlage ist erstmal festzustellen ist es dort sicher,
möchte natürlich auch nicht irgendwo in den dünen landen weil dünen sind.
Ganz schwierig zum durchfahren man muss halt
dass man irgendwo landet wo man sicher landen kann aber auch sicher wegkommt wenn man einen rover hat.
Und das sind die ingenieure die da hervorragende arbeit leisten,
bei der nasa und die die grundlage dessen bilden.
Auch die abteilung muss ich sagen hat auch wirklich hervorragende arbeit geleistet also die dass das ganze getue um um diese landung dieser mission hat irgendwie alles geschlagen.
Bis heute was man da so also außer etwas herausholen konnte also allein dieses seven mädels auf terror video
das ging ja irgendwie um die ganze welt und hat dann irgendwie alle auf einmal so mitfiebern lassen so mit dem
apparat abgesetzt wird aber hat ja dann auch alles wunderbar funktioniert was natürlich auch nochmal dazu beiträgt dass man sich das so merkt.
Ja der mensch von dem ich den größten respekt habe ist der der die ansagen macht im control während der landung und dann mit einer völlig ruhigen stimme sagt on mars.
Und da dreht durch okay aber was ist denn noch,
an bord gewesen also das ist ja nun bei so einem riesigen apparat nimmt man ja nicht nur ein instrument mit was man sowieso schon paar mal dabei hatte.
Nein ist so also wir haben das was
ems unterscheidet von spirit ist das was im ober selbst sich befindet.
Noch andere kleinere dinge aber hauptsächlich das was im robert selbst sich befindet
und das camp instrument der große laser der auf mast sitzt die chemie das da kommt auch der name laboratory her neu ist zum beispiel das instrument das.
Ein massen spektrum meter ein gast carmato grafen und ein blazer spektrum meter in einem vereint wir haben ein das bedeutet übrigens analyse sie wir haben einen ofen
in denen wir eine probe einbringen können aufheizen können und die gase die dann freigesetzt werden messen können.
Äh wir können das kommando grafik machen für organische moleküle wir können mit dem turnier blazer
kilometer hauptsächlich mit taten messen wir haben aber auch ein massen spektrum meter mit dem wir die gase messen können unter anderem
das heißt wir haben die gesamte bandbreite dessen was gas förmlich unterwegs ist vom.
Stickstoffdioxid carbon also kohlenstoff seine
zwei wasser el gase metall und so weiter und so fort dass wir messen können.
Und wir haben auch die möglichkeit eines sogenannten,
experiments wir haben dort neun
kleine reaktionsquote fässer in denen eine substanz drin ist die,
derivat station organische moleküle freisetzt ohne dass man heizen muss das heißt,
organische moleküle aus dem gestein in eine gastro fase umwandelt und wenn können wir die über das gas massen spektrum meter
in gaskocher grafen ins massen spektrum meter einlassen und können die organischen materialien messen das ist das.
Sam instrument wir haben aber auch chemie was ein
der fraktur meter ist mit dem wir ganz genau die mineral logi e bestimmen können auch da wird eine probe in den robert
eingebracht in eine kleine zelle durch die der röntgenstrahlen dann durchgehen kann und wo wir im prinzip renten der fraktion machen können genauso wie wir es im kreis zwischen labor auch können und dann sehr genau feststellen können
welche mineralöle vorhanden sind und das ist der das ist der große unterschied das ist auch warum das instrument so viel größer ist ein anderes instrument was auch.
Ganz ganz hervorragende ergebnisse geliefert hat und
nicht auf den spirit apportieren tirol drauf war ist camp camp kamera das ist ein laser mit dem man ein gestein öffne größeren entfernung.
Anschließen kann und dann entsteht ein plasma und dieses plasma kann man spektrum tropisch untersuchen und dann auch die gestein chemie
feststellen das ist sozusagen parallel zu dem was das kann das hat ein zwei komma fünf zentimeter durchmesser
fußabdruck wie man es auf englisch als football bezeichnet das heißt das misst die
durchschnitts zusammen umsetzung von einem zwei komma fünf zentimeter durchmesser punkt auf der oberfläche aber sie müssen.
Vor ihrem zu untersuchungen gestein davor stehen den arm aus fahren und den arm praktisch draufsetzen damit sie die untersuchung machen können das ist aufwendig das dauert.
Zeit der cam laser kann in einer entfernung von bis zu sieben meter im durchschnitt nehmen wir so drei dreieinhalb meter weil das,
entfernung ist wo es am besten funktioniert wie die besten daten kriegen sehr leicht ziele anvisieren.
Und bekommt dann zehn kleine punkte von fünfzig mikrometer durchmesser da bekommen sie dann natürlich die variabilität des gestein aber sie bekommen auch wiederum die gestein chemie und zusammen diese beiden instrumente erlauben uns halt sehr genau die geologisch umgebung zu charakterisiert zusammen mit verschiedenen.
Strahlen instrumenten die durch die kameras dazu kommen.
Das instrument mit den taschen ofen wo man sozusagen die kleinen proben reintut diesen ja dann immer verbraucht ne also man hat dann sozusagen so so und so viel schuss und dann ist irgendwann weg weil man man kriegt das nicht wieder leer.
Man kriegt es nicht wieder leer man kann aber wenn man weiß dass man eben äh hoch genug geheizt hat unter umständen die zweite probe mit in denselben ofen einbringen ähm.
Kommt immer darauf an dass das in entscheidungen die man von fall zu fall treffen.
Aber mit dieser camp ist im prinzip so viel durch die gegend schießen wie man möchte.
Cam und auch die können so viel durch die gegend schießen wie sie wie sie möchten kevin kann seine zellen auslernen aber das instrument wie gesagt das haben sie geschmolzen ist gestein drin das.
Das funktioniert da nicht mehr.
Aber man kann unter umständen die zweite probe einbringen.
Aber damit kommt die zumindest schon mal sehr nah so an unsere vorstellung von so sein wenn man so auf anderen planeten rumfährt und überall mit dem laser abschießt und dass man jetzt irgendwie keine gegner vernichtet sondern im prinzip ja die ganze zeit einfach überall
woraus besteht denn das alles.
Und das ist halt unheimlich wichtig denn wenn sie geologisch grundlage nicht verstehen dann können sie auch nicht verstehen wie,
die umwelt aussieht wie die umwelt auf wasser kontakt reagiert und wie die bedingungen wären wenn irgendwelche bakterien oder andere mikroben dort wären.
Und wie groß ist jetzt so der informationsgeber da pro meter so sind die erwartungen die ja sicherlich nicht gering waren an so eine komplexe chemische analyse auch schon erfüllt worden.
Ja ganz eindeutig ja ich meine äh so eine mission die erwartung war im prinzip zu beweisen und zu charakterisiert was.
Dieses dieses seebad dass wir dort haben eben an bedingungen,
bieten würde und der krater ist halt eine depression eine vertiefung in der sich seitdem ente gesammelt haben wir haben in dem laufe der mission jetzt diese segmente über eine gesamte
abfolge
frisiert und sie können sich das vorstellen dass ein setting mentor logg geologie in gestein schichten liest wie in seiten von einem buch
john krozingen der ursprüngliche prinzip der mission er hat das immer sehr schön eben mit dem buch verglichen dass sie mit jeder schicht die sie untersuchen eine neue seite in dem buch aufschlagen und.
Damit wieder ein neues kapitel.
Der geschichte diese die der geologisch und georg chemischen geschichte dieser landschaft eben
entdecken und was wir halt haben ist wir haben.
Ton mineralöle was ganz ganz wichtig ist denn ton mineralöle äh haben nicht nur die eigenschaft dass sie sich
nur in bereichen bilden wo wasser vorhanden ist sondern auch die eigenschaft dass sie zum einen.
In verdacht stehen katholisch wirksam zu sein je nachdem wo man.
Wen man fragt welche schule man sich anschaut wenn man den schritt machen möchte von vor biologische organische chemie zur biologie dann muss man gewisse dinge an einem ort konzentrieren in gewisser weise
ausrichten um eben diese marco moleküle zu machen und eine schule sagt halt das ton mineral oberflächen katalysator wirken können um das so zu machen
das heißt schon allein deshalb sind ton mineralöle sehr wichtig aber wenn sie.
Mikroben haben wenn sie hier auf der erde sich beispiele anschauen äh nehmen sie ihre garten erde die bleibt im sommer feucht auch an trockenen tagen weil ton mineralwasser aufnehmen und wieder
geben können und wasser speichern können also diese in ton mineralöle generell sind sehr sehr wichtig um die etablierten einer umgebung zu
zu fördern wir haben sehr viele soll fahrte gefunden
wir haben gleichung gefunden wir haben bereicherung gefunden
und von daher eine ganz variable georg chemie eine variable mineral logi e,
aber dann auch wieder den sehr dementieren prozessen zugeordnet werden kann wenn sie sich irgendwelche ähm.
Publikationen anschauen die äh veröffentlicht sind oder einfach auch nur auf.
Webseite gehen dann sehen sie was eine sehen sie eine sogenannte strategie grafische tabelle und diese strategie grafische tabelle zeigt.
Einzelne schichten die dann gröber könig oder feiner könig sind und gewisse eigenschaften haben,
damit und verstehen wir die geschichte dieses ortes die geologisch geschichte dieses ortes und wir verstehen die entstehungsgeschichte dieses ortes.
Und das ist was curiosity herausgefunden hat und immer noch dabei ist.
Gibt es dann ja auch schon so so so maß zeitalter die daraus dann schon abgeleitet worden sind wie man das auf der erde kennt.
Ja mahlzeit alter gibt's schon auch von den sachen die von satelliten beobachtet worden sind der mars wird eben eingeteilt in drei große zeitalter das enorm schien das experience und das,
zonen dass amazon.
Zeit in der eben oxidieren der oberflächen bedingungen herrschten so wie heute das.
Ferien ist die zeit wo man lange zeit für vermutet hat das soll vater entstanden sind.
Wofür wir uns hauptsächlich interessieren ist das nachher das ist die
frühester zeit auf dem mars von dem sogenannten
vor dem sogenannten happy bombardements bis zu ungefähr drei komma zwei milliarden jahre vor heute wo wir die entwicklung von fluss tälern gesehen haben wo die ganzen ton mineral entstanden sind und wo
alle hinweise sagen dass mars nass war wie warm wissen wir nicht genau aber auf jeden fall dass es fließendes oberflächen wasser
gab und das im prinzip lebens-
Freundliche bedingungen geherrscht haben auf dem gesamt planeten und natürlich.
Das bombardements ist also einschläge von entsprechenden asteroiden et cetera die auch auf der erde massenhaft runtergekommen sind zu einer zeit als halt noch sehr viel mehr loses zeug rumflog in unserem sonnensystem.
Drei komma neun milliarden jahre vor heute gab es einen kurzen zeitraum und zwar hat.
Zusammen hängt das damit zusammen dass die äußeren gast planeten ihrer orbit verändert haben und damit die asteroiden des kleinen material was wir haben,
nicht mehr in gravitation stabilen orbit zwar sondern dadurch eben die arbeits verändert hat und einiges eben nach innen geschleudert worden ist die sonne ist.
Größte gravitation
durch ideen wir haben das ist auf dem mond zu sehen das wäre auf der erde auch zu sehen wenn unsere erde nicht biologisch so aktiv wäre und inzwischen alles aus radieren hätte was damals entstanden ist und das ist eben auch in einigen terrasse auf dem mars noch zu sehen,
nicht überall es gibt halt auch deutlich jüngere ähm geologisch jüngere bereiche auf dem mars aber was für die mission in die follower the water oder nach lebensbedingungen freundlichen gegen den suchen wir suchen die,
die thomas die zwischen drei komma neun milliarden und drei komma zwei milliarden jahre alt.
Und in dieses zeitfenster fällt halt geil der fällt an das ende des zeitfenster vom nachher in syrien also hat wahrscheinlich den übergang in die ich mehr trockene.
Klima des maß gesehen und was wir jetzt machen
ist auch wieder wie auf der erde wir nehmen diese großen zeitalter und wir sehen was die steine vor uns sind und wir gehen schritt für schritt durch und
ordnen die steine die wir finden in gruppen in kleinere einheiten dann auch wieder strategie grafisch ein wie man sagt um.
Festzustellen ums mal um auf mein beispiel mit dem buch wieder zurück zu kommen um festzustellen was es seit der eins und also seite fünfzig von dem buch wie gehört das alles zusammen das ist die,
abfolge dieser geschichte wie müssen wir das erzählen damit es in der logischen korrekten reihenfolge ist.
Und auch um dann entsprechend wenn man später andere bereiche ähnlich intensiv nochmal untersucht das dann auch leichter korrigieren zu können zu schauen so ah okay alles klar dass so wie es hier aussieht ist das wahrscheinlich jetzt dieses zeitalter und.
Hier dieses diese dinge die gefunden worden die kurz erinnern gleichung zonen fiel jetzt gerade was nicht genau was das ist aber so das alles dinge von denen man erwartet hat dass man sie finden wird,
und jetzt freut man sich dass man sie gefunden hat oder sowas alles überraschungsei funde wo man sich dachte so boah was das denn.
Als geologie erwartet man vielleicht mehr als jemand der nicht geologie ist.
Ja sicherheit.
Wir hatten natürlich wir sind doch nicht gelandet ohne irgendwas zu wissen wir hatten intensive studien vom orbit gemacht das passiert schon wenn man die landesteile aussuchen
in mein
in diesem workshops da versucht da versucht man natürlich so viel wie möglich schon herauszuarbeiten was man von den satelliten aussehen kann das heißt wir hatten schon karten
von dem und hatten unsere vermutungen was eben wo sein könnte das beste beispiel ist vielleicht hiermit halt wo wir vom satelliten aus bereits gesehen haben dass dort
stärker
in den satelliten bildern zum tragen kommt und man sieht halt in den satellitenbild dann auch dass es eben eine logische erhöhung im gelände ist und
das dann auch vom boden aus zu untersuchen mit einem rover.
Ist immer ein zusammenspiel dessen was man schon weiß und dessen was man dann auf dem boden tatsächlich wenn man dort rumfährt auch sieht es gibt überraschungen die erste überraschung war dass wir eben dieses kondome rat gesehen haben.
Was nicht ganz,
unerwartet kam aber dann doch auch überraschend direkt dort wo wir gelandet sind.
Aufgetaucht ist aber das ist geologie sie haben eine gewisse auflösung vom satelliten wir wussten dass wir am ende,
eines kanals sind der sich also in den in den katherin eingeschnitten hatte wo wasser in den kader reingeflossen war,
dieses sogenannte fande postet gesehen also wenn wenn wasser aus einem steilen hang in eine flache rein kommt dann kann es nicht mehr alle materialien mit.
Das heißt es werden dort materialien abgelagert sie sehen das wunderbar im vorhalten land wenn die bach läufe die steilen hänge runterkommen und dann eben sich ausbreiten und die rolle dort ablagert ähm
ähnliche prozesse das hat man natürlich vom satelliten gesehen dass dort eben ablagerungen statt
gefunden haben dass man tatsächlich in soul sechsundzwanzig also sechsundzwanzig tage nach der landung bereits in konrad fotografieren kann war dann auch wieder eine wunderbare überraschung,
also nicht unerwartet im sinne von was ist denn das und das hab ich ja noch nie gesehen aber,
eine freudige überraschung ist eben dort so zu sehen wie wir 's gesehen haben und diese dinge auch die soll vater diese fahrt gänge wir wussten dass soll fahrte dort vorkommen das war eines der hauptziel der mission so fahrte zu finden
dass wir sie dort gefunden haben wo wir sie gefunden haben war ein bonus.
Und so es ist expo ration man weiß einiges man hat karten aber man weiß nicht alles und.
Anderes schönes beispiel ist gestein den wir sogar genannt haben wo wir trockenen risse gesehen haben.
An dem sind wir erstmal im prinzip vorbeigefahren und wenn ich.
Gefahren eine mission ist praktisch immer in bewegung
und dann und die analyse der daten findet parallel statt das heißt manchmal,
findet man eben etwas sozusagen im rückspiegel und zum old zucker sind wir dann nochmal zurück gekommen um eben zu gucken der hat trockenen risse trocken risse sind extrem wichtig weil sie sich.
Nur bilden wenn wiederholt es nass werden und austrocknen stattfindet.
Jeder kennt trocken risse der irgendwo lebt boston mineralöle gibt und wenn man eine pfütze hat und die trocknet aus dann bilden sich diese risse an der oberfläche aber die bilden sich nur durch wiederholt des nass und trocken
wechseln.
Das heißt man hat man auch im bezug auf die wasserfrei frage neue erkenntnisse gewonnen oder ist eigentlich schon alles bewiesen.
Wir haben durch das kondome rat halt nachgewiesen dass wir das,
dieser wasser kanal nicht ein.
Kurzfristige es hat halt mal die kurzfristig geregnet dann mal alles wieder.
Effekt ist sondern dass es ein effekt ist wo wasser über längere zeit geflossen sein muss der unterschied ist wenn sie eine sehr kurzfristiges wasser ereignis haben dann äh,
kommen materialien den hang hinunter und sie die sind zerbrochen die sind scharfkantig und sehr stark unsortiert.
Wenn sie einen langfristigen kontinuierlichen wasser strom haben,
dann beginnen sie die steine zu runden und diese diese rundung
sagt aus dass eben die das wasser über einen längeren zeitraum geflossen sein muss.
Um eben rundung und sortierung zu erreichen und dass wir das dort so gefunden haben war.
In gewisser weise neu es war nicht das erste mal wir sind auch nicht die erste mission aber es ist neu in dem sinne wie wärs jetzt
dort gefunden haben
auf der anderen seite was wir jetzt machen können dadurch dass,
eben die grundlagen in vieler sein sich gelegt sind ist mit größeren detail zu untersuchen
und wir haben auch ein sehr größeres instrumentarium die organische chemie die wir mit sam machen die metall sachen die wir mit sam machen die atmosphäre untersuchungen die wir machen das sind halt alles sachen die.
Sehr viel details detaillierter sehr viel intensiver jetzt mit dieser mission gemacht werden wenn er als es vorher passiert.
Auf der anderen seite haben natürlich die spirit and opportunity rover auch hervorragende erkenntnisse geliefert von daher sind wir nie
voneinander unabhängig sondern es ist immer ein.
Zusammenspiel dessen was man schon weiß mit dem was man eben jetzt findet.
Ich glaube ich hab 's eingangs jetzt gar nicht nochmal gesagt sag ich jetzt einfach nochmal beim also im gegensatz zu den mission vorher beim laboratory sind ja fest im team.
Dabei und das auch von anfang an wie muss man sich so die arbeit.
Vorstellen also das ding ist ja jetzt noch unterwegs man gewinnt jetzt am laufenden meter
neue erkenntnisse oder man kriegt zumindest dinge vielleicht auch bestätigt die man bestätigt haben wollte oder eben auch das gegenteil also dinge passieren und einiges dürfte ja nun auf der liste auch schon abgehakt
gewesen sein oder ist die liste so ewig lang dass man das ding dreißig jahre fahren bist du bis man die überhaupt bekommt also diese abstimmung so zwischen den engineer die halt die ganze zeit versuchen dieses gerät am leben zu erhalten.
Und im wissenschafts team die sich die ganze zeit neue sachen einfallen lassen wie muss man mit diesen prozess vorstellen wie läuft das weil es ja jetzt sicherlich auch nicht nur die open air university dir beteiligt ist sondern es sind ja wissenschaftler round the world.
Ja ja wir sind knapp dreihundert leute wenn ich's richtig im kopf habe.
Auf der wissenschaftlichen seite und natürlich mindestens so viele ingenieure und nase leute
wie man sich das vorzustellen hat ist wir sind in teams eingeteilt natürlich hat jedes instrument seine teams die dann auch wieder aus ingenieuren und wissenschaftlern bestehen
und dann gibt es aber auch eine struktur so wie man das mit jedem anderen projekt.
Man hier eine projekt struktur projektleiter wenn man's so übersetzen möchte ist zurzeit erschweren wasser war da der am pc ist und der das der als prinzipiell investigative hat das ganze über sieht und.
In letztlich dann wohl auch die letzte entscheidung treffen müsste wenn
wie eine entscheidung strittig strittig wäre um ihn herum hat er ein team von anderen leuten die eben mischen sind und die das ganze dir die leitung des ganzen haben aber wie man irgendwie muss man sich das vorstellen von,
wir machen long plans,
pläne dessen was wir über den zeitraum von vier wochen sechs wochen acht wochen zehn wochen machen wollen,
äh wir machen mit tom plans was machen wir in den nächsten drei bis fünf tagen und wir machen das was wir.
Nennen also was machen wir heute das ist also die struktur die planung struktur,
über dem ganzen was wir mit longdrink mit plans machen steht natürlich das was die mission erreichen möchte die mission goes charakterisiert die umgebung
charakterisiert die tabelle.
Und alle diese punkte die.
In dem missionswerk ziel festgeschrieben sind das ist unsere leitlinie und dann gibt es die sogenannten planer die haben das
wirklich im kopf und die achten da drauf es ist auch immer wichtig zu gucken welche ressourcen wir haben also,
energie datenmengen alle diese dinge aber auch die ressourcen wenn sie daten bekommen ziemlich kurzfristig vor ihrem nächsten planung
wie viel können sie in der zeit.
Das wiederum zum satelliten schicken müssen überhaupt leisten,
im bezug auf planung das also komplexität genannt wird.
Ist das zusammenspiel dessen was man eben erreichen kann an jedem tag ich bin bei der taktik planung planung beteiligt.
Das heißt die entscheidung zu treffen was machen wir heute.
Und das wird angeleitet von denen die die die längeren längerfristigen pläne
im kopf haben und es finden sehr viele diskussionen statt und mit den leuten mit den instrumenten teams mit den ingenieuren um festzulegen was können wir mit den heute vorhandenen ressourcen in der heute vorhandenen zeit
machen das eben in dieses konzept passt dessen was wir hier an geld gerader machen wollen
da wir aber den ganzen krater zur verfügung haben wenn wir eine mission hätten die so lange lebt wie opportunity und würde es uns mit sicherheit nicht langweilig.
Und ist das absehbar dass es so lange hält bisher geht's ganz gut ne.
Einen bisher geht's ganz gut für finger prost wie man so schön im englischen sagt.
Die wir haben einen unterschied wir haben keine solar panels wir sind also nicht solarbetriebenen sondern wir haben dieses.
Also ein radioaktive energiequelle und die haben natürlich eine lebenszeit soweit
ich es im kopf habe sind's vierzehn jahre wo man eben genug energie hat um den robert warm zu halten
und sinnvoll zu betreiben aber das wir sind natürlich mit unseren fünf fünfeinhalb jahren noch ziemlich am anfang und von daher haben wir noch ein bisschen weg strecke vor uns.
Aber kann durchaus sein dass es auch seine vierzehn jahre schafft ja.
Ich hoffe doch also in robert zu fragen wie lange er lebt das wäre so gut wie menschen zu fragen wie lange lebt und das thema wollen wir lieber nicht anschneiden.
Aber was auf jeden fall klar es ist,
rover sind zumindest was die maß betrifft einfach ein extrem erfolgreiches konzept also man hat einfach gesehen darüber es lohnt in den aufwand weil die komplexität des geräts ist,
enorm also was da alles feuer getestet werden muss und zusammenspielen muss damit es eben dauerhaft läuft mal ganz abgesehen von der durchgehenden begleitung und betreuung und dem fixen von
problem die halt auftreten wenn man während man das alles betreibt zeigt dass diesen aufwand lohnt.
Weil man eben einfach die möglichkeit hat durch diese bewegung ganz andere bild von diesem planeten zu bekommen.
Es kommt immer darauf an was sie wollen inside der länder den man ja schon mal erwähnt haben ist eine seis mische station das heißt der ist darauf angewiesen dass eben möglichst in ruhe.
Auf der oberfläche zu sitzen um ein maß erdbeben zu entdecken wenn man das machen möchte dann braucht man keinen robert.
Beziehungsweise wenn ihr jetzt so viele robert noch hinterher kommen sowie straßenverkehr stattfindet die erdbeben nicht mehr messen.
Ne damals ist groß und die gefahr dass rover mit urban kollidieren ist noch lange nicht gegeben ich glaube.
Engländer würden jetzt sagen das problem.
Nee aber mal ernsthaft gesprochen man muss sein instrument danach aussuchen was man wirklich machen möchte das
hängt damit zusammen was die untersuchungen sind das hängt damit zusammen wie langlebig man ist wenn man zum beispiel,
felix denkt der ja in der pool region gelandet ist wo es im winter.
Über friert die zeit die der gehabt hätte wäre eben nicht
genug gewesen um eine größere.
Fläche zu erkunden von daher macht ein land der dog sinn auf der anderen seite wenn sie den robert haben wie sie richtig sagen man kann eine gewisse strecke untersuchung man kann die perspektive
tiefe verändern man kann ein größeres areal untersuchen und wenn man jetzt ein exot mars anschaut man kann natürlich auch.
Sich dann eine,
optimale stelle aussuchen wenn man landet dann ist man darauf angewiesen dass man genau dort landet wo man landen möchte um seine untersuchung zu machen wenn man einen rover hat,
kann man von der landesteile in zum beispiel etwas komplexes teurer fahren wo die geologie das bietet was man eigentlich untersuchen möchte aber wo das die komplexe,
so wäre dass man eben
nicht landen kann aus sicherheitsgründen und alle diese möglichkeiten bietet ein rover aber letztlich wenn ich eine mission zu planen hätte wäre die erste frage was will ich überhaupt,
was brauche ich.
Und was braucht man es gibt ja.
Wenn man jetzt mal ein bisschen in die zukunft schaut was künftig jetzt für mission geplant sind dann wird der straßenverkehr doch schon zunehmen also als nächstes ist,
thomas am start in dem fall mal eine mission der esa und ich glaube auch die erste mission dieser art für die esa
das erste mal dass so ein opa gebaut wird und man sich quasi des maßes mal wirklich auf dem boden annimmt die
ganzen isa mission die halt im orbit agieren die waren alle sehr erfolgreich und da hat die ist er ja auch schon viel erfahrung gesammelt jetzt wird sich das einstellen und ich glaube auch die nasa ist schon wieder drauf und dran den nächsten robert zu bauen.
Und master
selbst hatte aber andere instrumente
des cam ist dann mit einem rahmen instrument kombiniert ab jetzt es ist nicht dabei diesmal
und äh wir haben auch keinen sam und kein kevin dafür haben wir maxi wer das ist ein instrument das sauerstoff aus der maß atmosphäre generieren möchte
und wir werden auch proben nehmen aber das ist auch wieder so ein schritt in sachen proben zurück.
Die erde zu bringen ist trendy der erste der eben dann mal die proben name übt.
Und äh dann wird als nächstes.
Ein rover wahrscheinlich konzipiert der dieses diese proben behälter holt.
Oder auch nicht das kommt dann eben darauf an wie erfolgreich das war.
Also man sammelt jetzt auf jeden fall schon mal probe und danach macht man sich gedanken über die vielleicht auch eingesammelt bekommen zu sagen um die dann wieder zurückschicken zu können.
Geben gehen wir mal zurück auf die apollo mission die apollo mission hat auch alles schritt für schritt gemacht da wurde auch erst einmal zum beispiel das dockin geübt und so weiter und in dem selben sinn äh wird jetzt mal proben name gemacht,
weil da müssen technologie
technologische probleme gelöst werden da müssen auch entscheidungsfindung probleme gelöst werden und da müssen probleme von planetkey protecting gelöst werden und von daher ist das ein erster schritt.
Was heißt das planen welcher planet so jetzt geschützt werden die erde weiter.
Planet protecting geht in beide richtungen planet protecting in richtung mars ist ähm natürlich sehr wichtig
denn wenn wir bakterien von der erde mitbringen würden und auf dem mars verteilen dann könnten wir nie mehr herausfinden ob es originale maß bakterien gibt.
Von daher ist es sehr sehr wichtig dass wir jedes jede mission die wir schicken entsprechend.
Anschauen wo geht sie hin.
Was wird sie machen wird sie mit potenziell mit wasser in kontakt kommen ja oder nein.
Planet protecting nach dem sogenannten kostbar protokoll nach.
Außen hin beachten aber natürlich ist das hereinbringen von proben.
Auf die erde genauso wichtig dass man eben sich ganz genau im klaren ist wie man diese.
Aus arbeitet und da gibt's experten wir sind von hier von der open air university.
Mit unserer astro biologie gruppe ein ganz ganz kleines bisschen daran beteiligt,
sowohl äh damit dass wir gerade eine gruppe aufbauen die sich.
Eben die erstellung von diesen richtlinien bemüht.
Als auch dass wir biologen haben die eben äh beraten tätig sein können in diesen gremien um zu sagen was mikroben können und was sie nicht können.
Und das sind internationale gremien internationale bemühungen da ist keiner alleine sowas kann man nur machen wenn sich alle einig sind.
Da wäre es auch ein bisschen blöd wenn man dann auf die auf einmal seine kamera einschaltet und man sieht so tierchen dies irgendwie auf dem mars geschafft haben die kleinen bücher sind ja bemerkenswert widerstandsfähig und ich glaube
was ist die würde man wahrscheinlich auch tatsächlich bis zum maß bekommen würden dann irgendwie immer noch.
Ja dass ich mein da kommen wir jetzt auch in den großen bereich der sogenannten pannen wo ja leute sich damit beschäftigen was,
an mikroben könnte es von einem planet auf den anderen schaffen.
Die andere frage ist ja nehmen wir mal an wir hätten hypothetisch des großes hätten äh leben auf dem mars könnte leben auf dem mars angefangen haben und die erde sozusagen infiziert worden sein.
Das ist das konzept
anja und eines der argumente ist mars ist kleiner wenn sie jetzt sich vorstellen dass ich maß und die erde als,
planeten parallel gebildet haben dann wäre der markus schneller abgekühlt
gewesen um zum beispiel wasser auf der oberfläche zuzulassen einfach weil er kleiner ist und das heißt leben könnte wenn man diese,
zeit betrachtet und die abfolge betrachtet rein theoretisch eventuell dort zuerst stattgefunden haben.
Und dann durch meteoriten.
Die erde gekommen sein und da gibt es eine ganze forschungs- disziplin die sich damit beschäftigt welche der verschiedenen mit mikroben von flechten algen bakterien.
Oder auch eben die bär tierchen was könnte so eine reise überstanden haben denn es ist kalt es ist trocken und es ist
hohe kosmetische strahlung wer könnte.
Hundert millionen jahre im weltall überleben und auch den einschlag überleben die drücke und die temperaturen überleben an dem einschlag.
Das was raus fliegt hat nicht unbedingt,
geschmolzen gestein gesehen im ganzen wir wissen von den athleten ne dass die eben keine schmelzen anschlüsse haben dass die maximal zwanzig gigawatt pascal gesehen haben.
Und damit auch nicht so hoch erhitzt worden sind also wer könnte in diesem gesamten
flecht werk von bedingungen dass wir jetzt kennen es eventuell von maß der erde geschafft habe,
und das ist ein ganz großes thema und auch ein ganz spannendes thema wie ich finde.
Klingt auf jeden fall bemerkenswert,
bärtchen also unglaublich resistent weiß man das mittlerweile.
Man schon ich nicht äh keine kann ich mal gerade meine kollegin.
Meine kollegin also zwischen ein gut erforscht das feld.
Es ist ein guter forscht des feld und was bakterien meistens ähm widerstandsfähig macht ist dass sie ihre diana gut reparieren können oder dass sie,
auch mechanismen haben sporen zu bilden das heißt sie
leben dann nicht im sinne von dass sie sich teilen und aktiv am leben teilnehmen sondern sie bilden diese sporen die geschützte kapseln sind in denen sie
die widerlichen bedingungen überstehen können und sobald die bedingungen sich,
eben wieder anfangen sich zu teilen und ganz normal ihrem leben nachzugehen.
Schau mal vielleicht nochmal ganz kurz auch nochmal auf das esa,
projekt also wir haben jetzt gesprochen und ich versteh das so im wesentlichen all zug
curiosity zwei selbst gerät aber andere.
Andere bestückung sozusagen aber wahrscheinlich wieder selber lande system und so weiter weil er hat ja alles schon mal funktioniert muss man nicht komplett neu erfinden macht sich ja immer ganz gut in der raumfahrt wenn man irgendwas wieder verwenden kann
was sind jetzt die ziele von thomas und wir sind da die chancen der isa da aufzuschließen.
So die die ziele von examen sind hauptsächlich eine zwei meter tiefe bohrung
natürlich wird thomas auch erstmal seine geologisch umgebung charakterisiert denn das ist das allerwichtigste zu wissen wo man eigentlich ist in der theologischen geschichte des mars das äh dafür haben gibt's kameras und so weiter und so fort.
Aber das wichtige ziel ist zwei meter tief zu bohren warum.
Die wenn man den maus sich als planeten anguckt und mit der erde vergleicht
der unterschied ist die heutige atmosphäre die heutige amazon hat sich sechs bis zehn minibar das heißt es ist sehr sehr viel.
Dünner niedrigeren druck als der erdatmosphäre mit ihren tausend dreizehn minibar.
Und das bedeutet das mars und die maße oberfläche nicht.
Abgeschirmt sind von der kosmetischen strahlung das geht mit ovg los hier auf der erde war das große thema das ozonloch und dass man zum beispiel in australien in sehr viel mehr strahlung abbekommt mars hat überhaupt
so eine atmosphäre das heißt ovg strahlung erreicht,
boden praktisch unverändert andere kosmetische strahlung erreicht den boden praktisch unverändert das heißt wenn sie organische strukturen an der oberfläche haben
dann werden die verändert oder ganz zerstört dadurch einfach dass die strahlung herrscht das oxidieren die bedingungen herrschen die auch wiederum von der strahlung,
erzielt werden.
Wenn man also auf der oberfläche organic findet curiosity hat oberflächen organic gefunden dann finden sie dort hauptsächlich.
Die dinge die sehr widerstandsfähig sind oder die sich,
oder dinge die sich in seine widerstandsfähiger moleküle umgewandelt haben das lässt aber nur sehr bedingt einen rückschluss darauf zu was das mal gewesen ist wenn man jetzt feststellen möchte ob man lebens spuren hat.
Stimmen natürlich hauptsächlich die original moleküle finden dazu muss man aus diesem bereich wo die strahlung wirksam ist rausgehen
und deshalb bohren wir weil zwei meter das ist so ungefähr die abstauben tiefe vor so ziemlich alles was an galaktisch und kosmetische strahlung reinkommen,
und deshalb möchte thomas eben bohren.
Und bohren haben wir ja schon gehört ist gar nicht so einfach.
Ja gut die dieses mol der hämmert ja und bohrt nicht.
Und der hat auch nichts was von oben widerstand leistet ich hab's jetzt auch nur in der presse gesehen aber soweit ich weiß versucht man ja jetzt mit dem greift kaum von oben ein bisschen widerstand zu leisten das ist natürlich was,
anderes
im vergleich zu dem thomas rover der eine große sogenannte box vorne dran hat also ein ein bor geschenke so wie man das auch hier auf der erde kennt von den bohrungen die wir hier auf der erde machen wo der gesamte rover eben das gegengewicht bildet
dem was man vorne macht es ist eine ganz andere technologie das können sie nicht vergleichen.
Und es ist auch ein ganz anderes ziel weil wir wollen ja nicht nur diesen sensor in den boden hämmern.
Belassen und mit ihm eine ebene baumen fluss messungen durchführen sondern es sollen ja diese drill die diese kerne die dort geburt die kerne die dort entstehen auch in den rover.
Eingebracht werden und mit rahmen und moma untersucht.
Wo man auch wieder wunderbar das zeitalter ablesen könnte dem anderen dingen.
Also die mineral energie und die organische chemie.
Genau einfach mal gucken ob zwei meter unter dem maß doch noch irgendwelche pärchen schlummern.
Der maß lässt alle nicht in ruhe gibt glaube ich,
kein anderes objekt im sonnensystem was ich ähnlicher beliebtheit erfreut das hat ja auch was mit zu tun dass man alle zwei jahre die möglichkeit hatte auch mal eben schnell,
hinzu reisen weil sich dann halt immer maß und erde in ihrem zyklus um die sonne.
Recht nahe kommen sodass eben dieser dieser zugang auf weitere zeit.
Bestehen wird ist davon auszugehen dass es wirklich alle zwei jahre immer wieder eine schippe draufgelegt wird.
Das kann ich ihnen so nicht beantworten denn das ist eine frage der.
Die von sehr vielen faktoren auch politischen faktoren abhängig ist äh sie haben also.
Zum einen die wissenschaftlichen fragen es gibt wissenschaftliche natürlich konkurrenz
zum beispiel wenn man jetzt im bereich der astro biologie bleibt und der frage sind wir eben alleine,
dann sind die also die eisbären
monde von jupiter und saturn auch ein ziel dass sehr viel weiter außerhalb liegt sehr viel schwieriger,
zu erreichen ist sehr viel schwieriger auch für die untersuchungen.
Sie ist denn sie können doch zwar auf der oberfläche landen sie haben aber wesentlich geringere sonnenlicht ein strahlung es.
Es ist eben ein sehr viel schwierigeres terra es dort zu erforschen und.
Aber sie haben wasser fontänen das muss man.
Fontänen und aber das was man natürlich als wissenschaftler eigentlich möchte ist mal gucken was unter dieser eisschicht eigentlich
ist und dann kommen sie in alle möglichen schwierigkeiten aber das mal beiseite gelassen.
Es ist eine politische
frage eine frage des geldes eine frage dessen was jede mission findet der inspiration der öffentlichkeit und ist ein so komplexes thema dass ich.
Hoffen würde wir fliegen
zwei jahre aber nicht mit sicherheit voraussagen kann was geschehen wird weil das hängt auch zum beispiel davon ab ob thomas sicher landet oder nicht was dann danach passiert und es hängt davon
was die europäische union als solches.
An entscheidungen trifft was sie machen möchte möchten wir zu den also die esa jetzt möchten wir die simons erforschen oder äh wie ist es mit dem marko venus ist ein
völlig nicht erforscht der planet die russen sind
paar mal gelandet haben da wunderbare sachen gemacht daten erforscht wollen wir mal zur venus das sind alles dinge die im kollektiv getroffen werden und von so vielen dingen abhängig sind das ist kaffeesatz lesereise wäre wenn ich jetzt hier eine.
Ja ich wollte gar nicht das nur auf die isa bezogen wissen weil nasa hat ja auch noch andere ziele darauf wollte ich eigentlich so ein bisschen hinaus
der maß beschäftigt uns ja mehr als nur wissenschaftlich ist ja sozusagen so ein mystische ort und vor allem ist ja auch so sagen wir mal der nächste kandidat für wieder so eine über anstrengung wo man mal alles einsetzen und sagt okay wir wollen jetzt mal wirklich mit
menschen.
Zum maß fliegen und wir wollen sozusagen das einfach mal machen und zwar einfach einfach einfach immer wieder was,
zu haben was man bisher noch nicht gemacht hat das scheint uns menschen ja irgendwie so ein bisschen in die wiege gelegt zu sein so etwas zu tun,
was mich jetzt frage ist,
wie gut sind wir denn jetzt vorbereitet also wieviel wissen wir denn jetzt schon um diese rahmenbedingungen einer eines eines maß fluges mit menschen
weil es mal ganz abgesehen von den rahmenbedingungen von raketen transport et cetera aber einfach nur was sozusagen was das verständnis des des planeten als solchen betrifft figur,
vorbereitet um dort auch sein zu können und im idealfall natürlich auch wieder zurück zu kommen.
Wir wären eigentlich sehr gut vorbereitet aus der wissenschaftlichen sicht denn äh wir kennen einige stellen recht gut aber jetzt mal
meine ganz persönliche meinung und nicht die meinung von nasa esa oder irgendeiner anderen raumfahrt behörde.
Das ganze thema ist sehr sehr viel komplexer wenn man sich das anschaut und mit dem mond vergleicht.
Wenn wir zum mond fliegen sind wir nahe wir sind in drei tagen wieder zurück egal was passiert
apollo dreizehn wäre um den maus nicht möglich weil sie monate unterwegs sind das heißt das risiko ist höher ich bin mir nicht sicher ob unsere gesellschaft heute
tage noch dasselbe verständnis von helden hat und von risikobereitschaft dass wir damals hatten das ist aber jetzt eine ganze
persönliche meinung auf der anderen seite wir kennen die geologie sehr gut wir wüssten was wir dort zu tun haben wir kennen
zum beispiel von von den messungen die curiosity mit seinem relation textur macht sehr genau
die strahlend dosis die wer bekommen also die nase bereitet ja im prinzip mit dem radio.
Curiosity mit maxi auf mars zwanzig zwanzig gewisse dieser schritte vor also der wille scheint da zu sein wenn man es so von außen betrachtet,
für mich ganz persönlich da hier in der astro biologie gruppe arbeite sehr viel mit biologen zusammenarbeite.
Denk ich ist es aber auch ganz ganz wichtig dass wir planet radio action also den schutz des planeten maß,
an erster stelle stellen denn wenn wir mit einer bemannten raum mission dort
ankommen dann bringen wir zwangsläufig uns mit wir können uns nicht so sterilisieren wie man
in stück metall sterilisieren kann und aus aus der sicht
eines mit den biologen zusammenarbeiten denn wissenschaftler s wäre es halt auch ganz wichtig dass wir dieses return haben dass wir eben erstmal uns anschauen können
ist da überhaupt was an der stelle wo wir landen wollen denn wenn man das einmal kontaminiert hat wir kennen das von der erde wenn man die wenn man ein.
Ökosystem eine oder auch eine landschaft
ohne irgendwas drin erst einmal kontaminiert hat kann man das nicht mehr rückgängig machen also von daher ganz persönlich gesehen wäre die erforschung dessen ob
ob es tatsächlich bio biologische rückstände gibt ja oder nein und zu wissen sicher zu wissen
worauf man sich in dem bereich einlässt halt auch ganz wichtig
aber auch das wiederum ist eine entscheidung die im kollektiv im internationalen kollektiv abgewählt werden muss was man jetzt machen möchte.
Also eher ein plädoyer für weitere robotik mission um einfach mal was rausholen was wäre denn wenn man so ein sample tatsächlich zurückgeführt
bekommt wie viel besser könnte man denn diese bodenproben auf der erde untersuchen im vergleich zu dem was derzeit das ems l leistet.
Sehr viel besser denn sie haben hier auf der erde
alle möglichkeiten nehmen wir eine ganz ganz einfache möglichkeit wenn ich ein stück stein hier auf der erde habe,
kann ich als geologie einen sogenannten dünn schliff machen das heißt ich kann mir ein dreißig mikrometer dünnes
von dem herstellen das auf ein glas träger aufgebracht wird und ich kann dann in mikroskop untersuchen wie mineralöle im verhältnis,
zueinander stehen.
Das können wir auf dem mars derzeit nicht das heißt ich kann zwar feststellen ich habe ein soll fat und ich habe ein box ich ich kenne aber nicht die die ganz genaue,
das ganz genau verhältnis der beiden und die textur wie die beiden miteinander verwachsen sind oder eben nicht miteinander verwachsen sind wo ich als geologie in einem dünnen schliff hier auf der erde sofort sagen kann die sind zusammen entstanden,
oder erst war das soll fat dann war der heimat it oder umgekehrt das kann ich im auf dem mars nur macros kopie in den kamera aufnahmen aber nicht mikroskopischen
das ist nur eines von ganz ganz vielen beispielen.
Aber gehen wir mal zurück zur apollo mission mit der ich schon mehrfach beispiele gebracht habe apollo hat proben zurückgebracht wir haben gerade jetzt in den letzten wochen.
Apollo proben geöffnet die noch nie geöffnet waren warum hat man die so archiviert man hat die so archiviert.
Uns allen klar ist dass sich die technologie weiterentwickelt das in der zukunft untersuchungen möglich werden auf.
Basis von erkenntnissen die wir zu dem zeit als die apollo proben zurückgebracht wurden noch nicht hatten technologische möglichkeiten aber auch
hypothesen weiterentwickelt werden die man dann in der zukunft klären kann und das ist etwas dass man eben nur,
die wir hier auf der erde haben und die wir hier archiviert haben leisten kann denn curiosity arbeitet heute.
Die proben die wir zurückbringen würden wer da von denen wäre auch in fünfzig jahren in hundert jahren noch etwas dafür.
Für wissenschaftler die dann ganz andere fragen und ganz andere instrumente haben um diese proben zu untersuchen.
Und das ist für mich eines der größten argumente und apollo hat uns gezeigt.
Und wenn diese argumente auch in der diskussion und zukünftige missionen eingebracht.
Soweit ich das höre ja.
Ja ist ja dann sozusagen auch immer noch einiges zu machen und zunächst einmal wäre es ja eigentlich auch ganz sinnvoll erstmal so eine mission zu machen weil
überhaupt erstmal vom maß zurückzukehren ist ja in dem sinne auch noch nicht gelungen beziehungsweise auch noch nicht so richtig versucht worden.
Weil es ist ja nun also makler kleiner sein als die erde aber hat ja trotzdem eine ganze menge masse spricht um die gravitation,
erstmal zu überwinden um von dort wieder zurück zu kommen auf jeden fall auch nochmal eine große herausforderung.
Ja das war so ein bisschen ans ende der sendung angekommen gibt's ja noch etwas.
Ja allen zu hören denn noch mit auf den weg geben möchte was wir vielleicht bisher noch nicht angesprochen haben.
Das einzige was ich halt finde ist wenn man in einer position ist wie ich es es ist eine der besten dinge die einem so passieren können und ich nehme mir da das zitat von steve immer sehr zu herzen der einfach sagt in joy
der menschen.
Ich habe das ja auch sehr genossen vielen vielen dank frau schweizer für die ausführung zu der boden erkundung auf dem mars.
Ja und wie immer vielen dank natürlich auch fürs zuhören hier bei raum zeit im nächsten monat geht's dann wieder weiter mit irgendwas anderem sehr interessanten bis dahin sage ich tschüss.